Fresh back from her lion hunting safari in Africa.
Esther,
cool.
You're here.
I,
I'm just this line mania today.
I asked her,
I'm paying attention is I can't know what happened with lions day,
but some dude,
uh,
killed,
like a loved lion that had a gps collar.
They lured away from this protected area where it was living and he killed it
and uh,
they tried to hide the fact that he killed it.
He's a dentist in Minnesota.
Yeah.
It's a sad story.
Tried to destroy the tracking device.
Why?
Why do you try to distort a track?
Because he didn't want to people to know that he killed this lion.
That was a protected line.
Apparently they lured it away from the protected area with the,
with meat,
it's still like drag meet behind a car.
I like to put the sense so that this thing would fall a scent and smell it.
And then he used a gps tracking device to find the line.
No,
the,
they found that allegedly according to them,
they found out that it had a tracking device after they killed it.
So they didn't know that it was a protected lion.
Oh,
well is it going to do with the lion?
It's going to put it in his office.
It just for the Instagram picture.
That's why a lot of people were pissed off because it's like this beloved lion,
but yet they're only doing it for like the photo,
you know.
Well,
he's got a trophy room,
I think,
cause he's killed everything.
This guy's killed fucking everything.
Right.
I think Jimmy Kimmel said he killed half a Noah's Ark.
Like literally it's fucked up.
Jimmy Kimmel start crying when he's talking about it last night on TV.
And I think it was legit.
I know it was legit.
He's on a bullshit artist.
But um,
yeah,
this guy's a,
he's a one of those trophy hunters that just wants to have these stuffed animals
in a room.
Wow.
Ah,
you know,
a big,
we talked about a big cat Derek the other day and he had contacted,
he wants to come out and fly out and uh,
and be on the show,
so when,
okay.
Yeah,
I'll definitely,
I'm on.
You know what,
we should do the,
he's one of those guys.
We should go visit them.
Yeah.
In Texas you go to Texas.
So where was his line killing?
Uh,
it was in Africa,
somewhere in Africa,
which is a fucking huge place.
Somewhere in Africa is like saying somewhere on earth.
I think it was in Zimbabwe.
Zimbabwe.
Yeah.
I want to know the two guys that dragged it out knew that this was about love
line.
Obviously if it was such a superhero in that that area,
like they,
it seems almost like a setup or something.
I don't know how much of a superhero line is the people that live there to the
people that live there.
That's a fucking mind.
You know,
I think a lot of the people that are like conservationists and are people that
are tourists and are visiting and that's a love line that the beloved lion will
kill you.
Just like any regular line.
It just not,
it's not the line.
Can you talk probably more mad at him then the woman who killed the giraffe.
Ah,
yeah.
Right.
Cause there's no giraffe king.
No.
You know in that moment with Simba,
like,
yeah,
I think we love lions a lot more than giraffes don't yet think.
We love a lot of animals based on cartoons.
We really do pay in cash.
We need a draft cartoon.
Yeah.
Oh,
toys r us.
They of have a draft,
but it's just a commercial we need.
Yeah,
we
need like a real car town,
like a half hour seen.
You ever seen the video of two giraffes fighting?
They like fight to the death to male giraffes over breeding.
They use their next,
they use their head like a whip and they,
they,
they swing their neck into each other.
It is fucking crazy.
And then they pull like tug of war.
No,
they just slammed their neck into each other's ass.
They slammed her neck into each other's body.
You know,
they have those like nubs,
like here it is.
Watch these dudes while she's twos go to war.
Oh,
we can see it on this one in front of us here.
Watching students go to war.
They,
they slapped their bodies into each other back and forth.
Come on.
How crazy is that?
Oh my God,
they like whip.
Put a wig on him.
Why would they put a wig on him?
Look cool.
Like hair,
like wailing everywhere.
White Wig.
It's just a what?
A crazy way to do battle.
Don't they really have legs?
It's like sword fighting kind of.
Then it's kind of cool if you were like a giraffe and you were smart and you're
like,
okay,
she would,
these guys are doing,
I'm going to kick his legs,
kick him right in the fucking,
oh yeah,
leg sweep it.
Just sweep the leg right there.
Yeah,
that,
that seems like I'll give you a massive headache.
Oh yeah.
Well what they had one of them walk away.
This,
these two guys,
they went to war about it and they walked away and his whole body,
it was fucked up.
Like he had just massive open sores all over his legs and his is open wounds all
over his legs and body.
Cause those horns,
they have their antlers.
They're slamming their antlers into,
into each other's bodies.
Bizarre.
Why did they get in a fight?
What do you think precipitated 100% their fight over breeding rights?
No,
no,
no.
They fight to make sure that they can breed.
They fight like all a giraffe essentially is like a type of deer.
It's like an antelope or something so that that kind of hooved animal and all
those animals,
they have real similar behavior and they have similar behavior where they grow
the largest ones with the biggest antlers,
the ones that get to breed and they clash heads to make sure that they're the
bigger ones.
And that's why they have these big impressive antlers that's still at the
females now.
Like,
Oh,
look at this mother fucker.
Yeah,
yeah.
The male giraffes get dark when giraffes,
uh,
when they start dominating the dominant male,
like you could see them,
they stand out.
They're actually darker than the other ones
now.
You know?
But yeah,
you,
you came here on a online day.
I mean I have my Twitter food feed has never exploded like this over an animal.
It's very interesting.
Yeah.
It's all over Facebook.
That,
and I'm also,
I've been scared.
All my Facebook peeps are scared about the hundred days,
hundred nights thing about the gang violence.
We no one really knows 100% for sure,
but it's like the La Times has a,
you know,
everyone's about it and it supposedly these two that somebody died in a popular
gang and uh,
supposedly the gangs to a rival gangs decided to have a competition who can kill
the most people in a hundred days here in la.
And so it's up like a Hashtag a hundred days,
hundred nights.
And a lot of people are calling bullshit on it.
But who knows,
you know?
No,
well it's the idea that we have so many people that are in gangs and so many
people,
I mean,
you ever talked to one of those La gang task force cars about how many gang
members or are in la?
Every day falls me,
there's a lot of fucking gangs and there's a lot of gang members,
a lot of disenfranchised young people that have nowhere to go criminal
backgrounds.
Fuck,
can't get a job,
can't vote,
can't join the military.
It's everywhere.
I think a gangbanger joined my high school,
like made high school.
Where'd you go to school?
East slide.
In high school.
Where's that?
In Chicago.
Oh,
you're from Chicago?
I'm from Chicago,
Ohio.
What'd you start doing?
Stand up Boston.
No Shit.
We're in Boston.
Uh,
the comedy studio in Harvard Square.
Oh,
I didn't even know about that place.
Where's that place?
No,
never heard of it.
Oh my God.
Is that the place above the Chinese restaurant?
Yeah,
I have been there.
it was there.
That's where my first show was.
I got mad at me.
They're some old guy got mad at me for something I was talking about.
I forgot what I forgot what it's about.
Nobody got mad at me.
Mad At my subject matter.
The audience was laughing hard though.
Was fucked.
It was weird.
It's like this one guy just decided that it wasn't fun in the wrong way,
which is too personal.
I wish I could remember what it was,
but I was just laughing like,
you really think I'm serious.
Like I forget what it was.
My might've been,
I'm not sure.
I'd be guessing.
Was he bigger than,
you know,
it was not bigger than me.
He wants to start a fight.
I don't think you wanted to certify it.
I think you just wanted to express just suggestion,
your suggestion box to your face.
It was really dumb because he was like,
like if you were at a show and everybody else is enjoying it,
it was all his laughter and all this fun going on.
Then you're like,
no,
you shouldn't be enjoying this because I don't like it.
Like that's stupid.
Just leave.
You know?
I've had people tell me that like,
I would enjoy your act so much more if you didn't use so many curse words or
didn't talk about like sex,
you know the whole time and I'm just like,
wait,
what do you want me to talk about?
Like that's just what I'm passionate about.
Sometimes you're passionate about sex,
it's beautiful.
It's just for days
now there's a lot of people they would like to present that sex doesn't exist
because nobody wants to touch them.
There's a little bit of that going on.
There's a lot of that going on for sure.
But most people are passionate about sex now.
There's a lot,
but there's some people that don't like you to talk about it and that's like New
England.
Like that area.
That's a big thing down there.
Like that's a very buttoned down town and the little very conservative and a lot
of ways like everybody wears Khakis and like blue collared shirts from j crew,
you know that's like the Boston uniform.
There is a lot of that going on.
Yeah,
it's a very,
because it's in a lot of ways it's a liberal town,
a democratic town,
start comedy in because they're so tight that you make them laugh and then you
go somewhere it will be like,
oh,
this is so easy.
Those Boston people are so hard.
There's some,
some of them are tighten up,
tie in.
The other ones are mean and drunk.
So you got two good groups to pull from the drunk Irish people.
Yeah.
Well it's a good spot to start that,
that,
that Cambridge place was known to be like a good little spot.
That's Rick Jenkins,
right?
Yeah.
You know,
I feel like he could,
he could have like a big comedy club.
He like,
he always prided himself and not advertising.
He's like,
we don't advertise it and look,
there's still 20 people here on a Saturday night.
And I'm like,
you should advertise.
Like,
you can make so much money if you like grew the club because yeah,
it's been there for awhile.
People have very strange ways of looking at things.
Then they just decided this is the way,
oh look,
I'm always aren't this way.
Right.
Not Advertising it.
Comedy Club seems pretty silly.
Like how the fuck is people were supposed to,
yeah.
I mean,
he's here this week.
Who knows?
You know,
like why would anyone go there?
Right.
Yeah.
That doesn't make any sense.
But,
so how many people were out of there?
There was this one gay dude that was there that was really fucking funny.
Like really flamboyantly gay dude.
He was hilarious.
I forget his name.
I want to say he's Iranian.
The calm person in Tripoli.
No,
he's not.
He's Armenian.
Um,
I forget his name.
K Do following them on Twitter for a while.
I lost track of him.
Saw him years back though.
He was very funny.
The comedy studio?
Yeah.
From that spot.
A lot of people came out of there,
but there's not that much besides there.
Right.
I mean,
what other places really grew open mind?
They still have open mic nights there.
I don't know.
You don't know?
You never go there?
I don't know.
I haven't been there in awhile.
When did you start doing stand up?
Like I'm
10 years ago.
10,
11 years ago.
Yeah.
But I had a full time job when I started.
What were you doing?
I was a sales rep.
I was slinging pens,
pens,
kind of pen.
You're holding?
Yeah.
That's why you were automatically,
you like holding this pen,
like displaying it?
Yeah.
She has all the tricks.
He knows.
Let me see.
Let me see your moves.
Well,
it's not really that hard while you do it.
Yeah.
Okay.
What are you doing?
You just going back and forth?
Yeah.
Okay.
I'm pretty sure I can do that.
Can I get a pen?
Okay.
Let me see what you're doing here this year.
How's that?
Yeah.
It doesn't seem that hard.
My doing it.
No.
You have to get like the right balance.
This is amazing.
Everybody like in library students
college drum stick,
throwing the stick.
Oh,
okay.
It looks,
it looks cooler now.
No,
you're doing it wrong.
You have to do it between your thumb and your index finger.
Between your thumb and your index finger.
Put the bottom of the pen here like in that little pocket,
right?
You have to place it here.
Oh,
there you have to put this here.
So what did you do you,
you salon pens like you used to go door to door,
like offices and stuff.
That's not how pens are sold these days.
Everybody says door to door
encyclopedia.
Have you ever bought a pen?
Give them samples
to everybody?
Yeah,
he gave me the best piece of advice anybody ever gave me about driving.
He was driving back and forth from Boston to New York and I said,
how do you do it without going crazy?
When I sit in the car and I say,
this is what I'm doing,
this is what I'm doing.
I'm driving now.
I don't freak out.
I don't say,
God,
I wish I wasn't driving.
How many more hours is there to go?
I just say,
this is what I'm doing,
and that's what I do.
Now.
When I drive,
I just say,
this is what I'm doing.
I'm driving this indie music or mostly mostly like books on tape or maybe
podcast.
More than one user
driving.
I love to listen to music.
I have to listen to music,
have to,
I don't have to like,
I'll listen to like talk shows and stuff,
but like something,
it's just so powerful to drive while playing meet,
but while blasting music,
you know,
like you just have,
I just have like a party in my car.
I'm driving by myself and I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
Why did you pick that more of a Katy Perry?
Love Katy Perry.
That song was brutal.
I would like to introduce you to a bunch of California girls are gross.
Yeah,
Monster.
I know all these California girls are getting like the beach boys song too.
They get all this free publicity,
you know?
Oh,
could,
there's no song about Illinois girls.
There should be,
right?
No.
Yeah.
My girls are solid Texas girls.
Those are some solid girls,
right?
Yeah.
Texas origins girls,
I think Texas.
Yeah.
About Florida?
No.
If you want to know what daisy that a worshiper land,
if you want to buy pills.
No,
all them,
all of them are coke heads.
All of the Florida girls.
It seems like that's probably the state is between Florida and Arizona.
It's the state.
We can guarantee if you go,
I'm going to run into people coked up.
Oh yeah,
those are these two spots
I find coke.
Yeah.
You know what,
that,
that did happen to me at a show in Florida once somebody offered you these
girls,
they were all like,
you know,
dressed out like dress like they're going to the club or something,
and they,
after a show,
it was a comedy show in a barbershop in Wynwood.
And after the show,
these girls came up to me.
They're like,
yeah,
you know,
they're like,
come,
come.
And they like brought me to the bathroom and they pull out a key with coke on it
and were like handing it to me to be nice,
I guess.
Like let her have the first sniff and I was like,
no,
I don't.
I'm like,
I don't do that.
Then the hate,
you know,
turn on.
Yeah.
Did they,
I don't remember.
She took it for coke.
I mean,
why would you turn down coke?
Wow.
Yeah.
Coke is fun.
You don't know.
You've done coke before.
You've had a
you twitch and like not stop talking and I just start freaking out like I'm on
too much coffee.
You know,
I never did it,
but I did drink the tea.
I drink this tea called Mata de Coco.
It's made out of cocoa leaves and I couldn't shut the fuck up.
I did it with a Stan hope and I remember I kept telling him,
dude,
I can't shut the fuck up.
This is driving me crazy.
And you're aware of it?
Yeah,
it's terrible.
It's the worst drug for me.
It's horrible because it's like,
it's the are like escaping.
It makes you stay up so late that it does that.
Like you're just the whole next two days that are just wasted.
You can't be productive with anything.
Yeah.
I have a friend who just did ecstasy and he said the same thing,
said after it was over,
like the next day he felt so shitty.
He's like,
I could,
he couldn't do anything.
There's a way to do ecstasy,
right?
New Mood,
take a shit load of new mood before you go to bed.
Just see like vitamin C and that's one of those things where you can do it
correctly.
And I've known,
I've had it where I've woken up and hadn't to zero hangovers.
And he's really funny
fit though.
And I wonder if the difference between a guy that,
uh,
is like always working out and eating healthy and drinks a lot of water and
takes care of his body.
Like the kind of heat when he really feels like a shitty day or as you booze it
up all the time,
you're smoking all the time.
We got some.
Okay.
Anymore,
right?
Well I'm still off.
I kind of fucked up in Toronto.
So are you back on now?
I'm just not,
I'm just having a few a day now.
Thank smoking cigarettes.
Yeah,
Brian,
I can,
have you ever tried to be hypnotized?
No,
I that doesn't work on me.
it will work dude.
You just got to get a real person.
I get people that say that.
Read that book.
No,
I hate reading books so much that like fuck this book and everything.
It stands for.
Books are awesome.
It's just wasting my time.
Like I,
I look at a book and I'm like,
I,
I'm thinking like a million things.
Other things that's like when you say you're in the car playing music,
I'll drive and sometimes realize that I'm not even listening to anything cause I
have a million things I'm at thinking about like I'm multitasking all over the
place.
So you can't read a book because you can't concentrate enough to read a book.
I mean,
I can read a book and make myself concentrate to read a book.
You never sit down and read a book.
He never like read the finishing.
Not since the Internet was made cause I read the Internet.
Yeah,
eyes are bad.
Deteriorate my,
I like 10 years.
I have to like give your eyes a break.
Jesus.
I read a Stephen,
I read a Stephen King and we're going to be doing a benefit for him in 10 years.
Like please help save Brian redbands eyes.
You know the surgery costs don't you
really close to some artificial lens.
Did you see that thing that they had on the Internet recently?
They are creating some artificial lens for the human eye.
That's way better than any vision [inaudible]
you'll ever have.
I thought they already had that.
Didn't they have their first implant?
I don't know,
but there's some new one that they've developed some artificial lens.
See if you can find it,
but they,
there was some talk about it.
They were like,
why would you Catlins no,
it's going to be like something they insert into your eyes.
Your eye.
Yeah.
They're going to do surgery on you.
What do you think about?
What do you think about people who want to put chips and kids to prevent
kidnappings or to be able to find your kid?
It sounds like a great idea if that's what it does.
If it prevents kidnapping and so he could find new kid.
The problem comes when people use it for other reasons,
like to know where your kids are because I don't like you or to know where your
kid is when they become an adult.
Maybe someone doesn't like their opinion on something or maybe they're about to
expose some business corruption or government corruption.
When people know where they are at all times,
that seems fucked up.
It just seems fucked up because we can't quite track everything that everybody
does.
I think eventually we'll be able to track everything everybody does all the
time.
Like this is radio lab show called eye in the sky.
What is this?
The implant is that,
what does it say?
It's treated.
Uh,
BC optometrist sees way for bionic Lens and plant.
Imagine seeing three times better than 2020 vision.
Even at the age of a hundred or more.
That's the future.
So this radio lab podcast called the eye in the sky,
uh,
is,
I think that's the name of the episode.
And it's all about these,
this technology they developed that they put on planes and they fly these planes
overhead and they take detailed images of everything on the ground.
So they do it like click,
click,
like it's constantly as it's flying,
taking millions and millions of photos.
So if something happens,
what they can do is find out where it happened when it happened,
then go to the eye in the sky footage that go to that section of the footage.
They go,
okay,
let's take it to three 30 today.
Yup.
There's the car,
there's the guy who gets out of the car,
there's a guy getting shot.
The guy gets back in the car and drives off.
Let's find out where the cargo is and they just follow the car.
They,
so they have all the images of everything that's happening and they're going to
use this in places like Iraq and they're going to try to use this in places like
Detroit and places where there's a lot of crime and a lot of violence,
but you know,
people are resisting it obviously because they're going to,
they're going to catch people doing all kinds of stuff.
They're going to catch people cheating on their wives and their husbands are
going to catch people stealing from work.
They're going to catch people not feeling like work.
Yeah.
Fill in the blank.
You say you're here but you're there.
Someone's going to have access to it.
You said you couldn't work because of this,
but we have footage of you at home.
It's just gets weird.
It gets weird when someone can just find where you are all the time.
But it kind of seems like that's where it's going.
It kind of seems right there.
Yeah,
almost.
Yeah.
You know,
like my problem with like putting chips in kids is that like,
okay,
so the,
it'll prevent people from predators,
from the kidnapping kids,
whatever.
But what if he finds where the chip is and then like scrapes it up.
You know what I mean?
Like he could hurt the child if it's like implanted in their skin.
That's true.
But I don't think you're going to save that kid by not having it in their skin
when he's going to fuck the kid and kill him or whatever the hell he's going to
do.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I see what you're saying.
Like someone would want to cut it out,
but if they could find it,
it's kind of person who would cut an implant out of a kid is not planning on
doing,
you know?
Well,
other than that,
my intentions are completely altruistic.
I fucking hate chips.
I just have to cut the chip out of this kid.
You're dealing with it.
So it's a weird privacy issue that I think eventually it's going to get to a
point,
it was going to be a moot point because there's going to be so much access to
where everybody is all the time.
It's going to be pointless.
Well,
like
these cameras are just getting more and more HD.
But like you'll be up to like just take,
take out your phone,
take a picture and like you're in line at Starbucks or whatever and pulls out
their credit card
to pay.
You'll be able to take a picture and then just know that that person's whole
credit card number,
you know,
like you're going to be able to zoom in so much.
Like this thing is going to get more and more spreading the fingers.
Yeah.
They used that um,
are in the sky thing in Juarez to catch this man who had killed this,
a female police officer that shot this female police officer or may or something
like that,
some female person in charge.
And when they shot her,
they followed the car back to this house and then they backed up and they were
able to follow all these other cars back to the house too.
And it turns out this is his house that was filled with a drug cartel members
and they were hit men and they would just run around doing murders and robbing
people and they were all hold up in this one house,
like a fucking movie.
And so they just stormed the house and arrested everybody.
So they're trying to use it as like one of those things where the saying that
this is eventually going to be something that comes in very handy and it's going
to be everywhere.
How's that eye in the sky deal with clouds?
Like if it's like an Ohio could be cloudy for a week.
It's a good question.
I mean they probably fly under the crowds if possible.
If not,
there's probably nothing they could do.
Yeah.
So if you're going to want be at the farriers criminal live in Ohio in the
winter,
cloudy day.
Yeah,
it's a good point.
You could just put those chips,
you know,
and the kids putting them on their Dicks of a kidnapper takes the baby.
They're not going to ruin the best part of the baby that you know.
And that guy cut the dick out,
Brian.
I'm like put it in the Dick Hall.
Best part of the baby.
It's already show cars.
Gonna fuck up the good.
Think about that before you said it.
Did you go,
this is the good thing to say right now.
This is perfect.
This is going to be awesome.
Everyone's gonna enjoy this show.
Everybody thinks like me.
This is perfect.
What did you,
we talked briefly last night about that alien,
that CIA,
it's just hilarious story.
It's a really interesting,
and if you listen to the interview of the,
supposedly this guy died,
they found him in an SUV in the Pacific Palisades and he was,
had been there I guess for four days.
And what happened is his girlfriend knew that he died and thought he was a half
a hybrid of an alien and a a CIA agent.
So he thought,
she thought she better leave the body.
The government knows he's dead.
He'll,
they'll take care of the body because he's not supposed to know it exists type
thing.
So went up to Washington and uh,
they,
the cops found the body.
He's been there forever and they go into his house.
He has millions of dollars worth of guns.
And then he also has large amounts of cash everywhere.
That's what they're saying.
Thousand 200 guns.
It's not millions of dollars.
They said last night on the news that it was a a collection.
We're chameleons
a million if each guy is worth 1000 bucks.
Right?
I guess some of them are just really like antiques I collectors and stuff like
that.
It's like huge collection so it doesn't look like he's like was a broke,
broke,
right?
And $230,000 in cash.
14 vehicles stashed around Los Angeles.
14 vehicles registered to him,
including an SUV designed to drive under water.
He's a nut and the SUV to drive under the water.
It's something that this new ABC seven,
it's just blowing up a portion that's actually a common thing that you put on
the bottom of the SUV.
So when you run over a puddle as it doesn't flood out,
the engine will sort of,
it's not,
you don't put it on the bottom,
it's a snorkel,
it goes out the the front fender.
Right.
It's real common for uh,
like off road vehicles like Lang Rovers,
like defenders,
those Land Rover defenders.
So that thing with a big pipe tube that comes off the side of the car,
you seem in jeep,
sometimes a Toyota land cruisers,
a lot of times they hooked those up with them.
People just like it.
They like the fact they could just,
I could float,
can drive underwater bitch play this video.
I want to hear this
Jamie.
1200 guns.
That seems a little,
a little excessive commercial,
uh,
by,
they haven't really released a picture of him or any news and he's had prior
convictions where he's gotten off,
but where you could only get it off if you were like somebody that works high up
like,
well,
you mean arrest?
He had a gun,
I believe at lax or something.
There's a lot of message boards that are really digging into this guy and
finding all this interesting stuff that he register all these guns under him.
That's what it looks like.
It was all somehow done with hair.
Body of a man is found near he's Pacific Palisades home.
That was stuff that,
especially the weapons during a story connected to the disappearance of an ox
starred a woman.
Because I was doing more low all night.
Sure.
Panelists,
age with a man's body was found abandoned and decomposing.
Very Nasal Carlos.
Well,
this is definitely a very straight scotch.
The man was found.
The guys are drinking scotch or his fiance's home in Pacific Palisades.
Nice House who was missing work for the fiance and other wild stories at the man
was a secret government agent and possibly part alien from outer space.
Wait a minute from out of space,
not Mexican.
I shut them down.
Is decomposing body in his SUV inside the home.
A huge cache of weapons.
Aussie.
Aussie has an amazing story.
A story her attorney found a bit far fetched.
Thought he was crazy.
It sounded crazy to me.
Catherine Nub.
Ron Claims Lash actually died two weeks earlier on July 4th in a parking lot in
Santa Monica.
Nebar on say she and the missing Oxnard woman,
Dawn Vad bunker tried to save his life and they work for about three hours
trying to keep him alive.
He refused nine one one.
He didn't want to go to the emergency room.
He didn't want any police,
so he died there.
Neb.
Ron says she then took him back to his home and left him there.
She believed that he was involved in some surreptitious activities,
governmental projects,
whatever,
and so her instructions were that if anything happened to him,
they,
whatever they is,
we'll take care of the body.
Favorite being watched all the time.
I was told they were being watched all the time.
I was told or house was being watched all the time.
Never on an bad or claim.
They traveled bunker to Oregon to forget about what happened.
Never on returned two weeks later and was stunned at what she found.
When she got back.
The body was still in the car and that's when she decided she better call a
lawyer.
Ron says when he thought the police had guns,
six and a half tons of ammunition and $230,000 in cash.
That bunker was found alive and well in a motel in Oregon.
Meanwhile,
vet bunkers.
Mother adds another twist about Jeffrey Lash.
We were all told that he was half alien ass man.
He was here to save the world and he was higher than a CIA.
Special labs for the government.
What detectives are now working on the downturn?
This is actually on the news and checking to see if anyone else has said at
least sketch Pacific.
Now you don't have any pictures,
no pictures,
no photos,
but at least get a drawing.
There's one drawing that looks a lot like will Smith for men and black too.
It's so stupid that all you have to do is have some guns and some cash and a
stupid story and you'll make the news.
I mean that's really what this is about.
This is really about guns and k oddly no contest.
All we know is he was involved.
No,
you don't know anything.
This is what you know.
You got guns and you've got cash and you've got a dead dude.
And because of that,
everybody is getting crazy.
That half alien dude,
like if you only have like five guns,
who would be like,
well he was a gun enthusiast and if you had 20 guns,
people were like,
well what was he planning when you have 1,200 guns,
then you're on TV.
You didn't make the news.
And what's weird is that most gun collectors don't usually have ammo for all the
weapons because they never plan on firing.
And they are these guns and he had ammo for all this.
I don't think he was a,
oh,
he's suffering from late stage cancer.
I don't think that's um,
he's a collector as far as he's,
I mean he's got all those guns,
but it's not like he's got them in cases like this is Christopher Columbus.
He must get anybody with a last name lash.
I know it sounds like the terminator movie,
her real name and her name was bunker in that picture.
Like what,
what?
Scroll back up to that picture Jamie.
What does it no down?
Yeah.
Lash on thousand fires.
14 specially equipped cars among other strange,
unusual items.
So what does that is like work bench in there and look at all the piles of cash.
I mean in all they're saying all the cars were specially equipped,
you know,
like with weird things.
So He's a nut.
He's probably one of those preppers.
It's just amazing that this can actually become a story just because you have to
catch a movie out of it.
Yeah.
Are there any,
who's going to play less?
This is priority a movie,
right?
Um,
Christian Bale.
He's gonna play him.
It's going to be like an ironic comedy.
No,
you know who they're going to get what's to do with the cleft palate.
You,
Joaquin Phoenix.
He's going to do it.
He's going to play it like that though.
I'll be bloated,
cooked dead guide number two for the,
did you see,
did you see his dumb movie,
that movie that everybody was telling you that was really good that walking in
Phoenix moves?
It's very strange.
Some,
some recent movie that he did like Real absurdist strange movie with Joaquin
Phoenix with no,
it wasn't her.
Yeah,
it was like a,
uh,
I watched,
I was like halfway into it and I was like,
yeah,
I'll fuck out anything.
The girl get in trouble kind of.
Cause she was playing an Asian and she's white.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Stone Aloha movie.
I don't think that's it.
It was a,
it was a movie about,
I don't even know what it was about.
It's just a ridiculous movie.
I think it was a private investigator or something.
Halfway in the movie.
I shut it off.
I'm sorry.
I can't even do this.
I never do that.
I almost always watch a movie all the way to the end.
That's how I had a movie theater.
I get up and fucking walk that get hard movie.
I get a harvest bad.
There's not one will far Ferrell movie that I have turned off halfway through
it.
That movie was horrible.
Uh,
Kevin Hart and Will Ferrell,
Kevin Hart,
Kevin Hart kills it as a comedian.
Just kills it.
He's killing it on the road.
He's on the cover of rolling stone now.
I think put a lot of people don't like his movies.
I don't know what that's about it.
He's just not good then.
It's not good as you.
Do you think he's doing too many movies?
Does he just just jam them in there?
Like whatever they come with money that they think is going to sell?
I don't think I've ever seen a Kevin Hart movie.
Second only have that one.
The judge,
he doesn't turn down his volume.
You know,
he's always on like level 10.
That's what it bothers you.
I don't know.
I don't know if I've seen the Kevin Hart movie,
but I'm just assuming that he's always that way.
High Energy Inherent Vice.
That's the name of the willing,
that poster a lot of people told me.
It was amazing.
Like this is such a cool movie.
And I was halfway into it.
I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
What are you doing to me?
You fucks good.
Pallister though.
Oh,
it's,
it's stylistically a very cool movie.
And I loved that
they can do that.
All the residuals from this movie should go to the graphic designer for this
poster.
And then the people put together the traders or the producers,
you know?
But it never goes that way.
Well,
it's got this 1960s vibe to it,
or 1970s vibe too.
It's just a very strange movie.
Just didn't,
didn't get into it.
So,
uh,
you're on girl code,
an girl code.
What do you do for that?
What does that involve?
Being a talking head.
So it's like one of those things where things play in the news and you start,
you comment on it.
They don't do the news,
they just give you topics
and Hoff.
Did he do that?
Well I did it like once a month when I did it.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I'm not doing anymore.
Stopped
was like I've had enough.
I've had enough of you guys dressing me up like I'm a 14 year old girl.
So they did.
Yeah.
Like I would have like bows in my hair.
What is that?
That's racist,
right?
Well they would like make all of us look like that.
All the girls on the scene,
I mean not like all of them,
but maybe some of them
know how many black girls.
No diversity on girl code.
Like behind the scenes,
but talent.
The talent.
Yes.
Did they make the talent?
The black girls?
They're 12
I don't know.
You don't know?
You should know.
You ask him.
Taught me how to
go off on the spot.
I don't know.
Kanye West,
her damps per day.
How many times a day does she get damped?
If she were to check,
everybody listening would want to know what you're talking about,
but it seems like those shows,
that's like pretty much
credit.
You don't get a writer's credit,
don't get paid very much.
It's a wild life show,
and occasionally Esther come on
people's opinions on stuff.
They have those VH one shows.
Basically they show clips splice in between people talking about like cherry pie
or something like that,
and that's really what the whole show is,
but yet the people that do it,
they don't get paid that much.
It's one of those little sneaky things.
They just figure they get you and
then somebody makes a lot of money.
Like Byron Allen,
Byron Allen Comics unleashed with Byron Allen.
The whole show is Byron Allen talking to Comedians and they,
hey Esther,
I understand you like zoos and you'll just start talking about the zoom.
No.
Can you make it sound like he's not forcing it so much?
It's all forest.
It's all forest and no one gives a fuck.
But that's the whole show.
And but he sells that show.
Byron Allen grew up around show business like what?
His mom worked for David Letterman or no,
not David.
Johnny Carson.
Oh Wow.
So his mom would clean,
would clean her,
his office and he would see the whole taping and he'd be a little kid standing
there like six years old watching Johnny Carson,
like say how to do it in the parking lot and then go on stage and make the magic
happen.
That's probably why he does it.
Like old school like that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does it.
That's,
that's who he watched every day.
Don't you think when you watch a talk show today,
like if you watch like,
um,
anyone,
Fallon or any,
any of these new talk shows?
There is,
it seems so weird to me that no one can move away from the desk.
Yeah.
You have to have a fucking desk and pretend like you're working in an office and
right next to you in most awkward way possible has to be someone sitting in a
chair next to the desk.
Why is it made to look like an office?
It's so strange.
Wouldn't be couches,
be better bed.
It's kind of like a doctor's office or something,
like you're sitting next to a receptionist.
It's like you don't even face them.
It's the weirdest way to have a conversation.
It's like if we,
we were,
the cameras were here where Jamie is and you and I will be talking like this.
That's,
that's literally how it would be doing the show.
We'll be right back.
And you,
the camera's facing you and you'd go sideways.
The first talk show host who had a desk set up on his stage,
probably par Jack Parr who was before.
Is that who it was?
That was maybe Jack Harlan didn't like wearing pants and he just wanted to cover
his lower body.
Who Do you think was the original talk show host on TV?
What do you want to say?
What was the original television talk show?
I have no idea.
I'll go with Jack Paar.
That sounds good.
Yeah.
I don't even know if that's his real name.
Okay.
Wait,
you talked showing Steve Allen was a big one for a while.
Late night talk show Wikipedia,
Dat,
dat to that on that.
Um,
all right.
Let's go with history.
United States forties and Whoa.
Forties okay,
so they had radio ones,
so they had these old time radio shows.
That's cool.
So they didn't have the two chairs and since Sullivan show,
Ed Sullivan might've been one of the first ones,
right.
That aired on,
whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Ed Sullivan,
originally known as toast of the town,
which aired on CBS Sunday nights from 1948 to 1971 holy shit.
Did you know I have no idea.
Jesus Christ,
23 years.
That's insane.
33 well,
that's insane.
23 years.
Wait,
48 to two doing the math
to 70 what?
(712) 037-0120 three years.
Melvin barrel.
Also,
I was at a show and 23 Michael Jordan,
Milton Berle had one in 48 on NBC.
The shows aired once a week in the evening time slots that would come to known
as prime time.
The first show to air on late night was Broadway Open House and aired on NBC in
1950 it was canceled a year later.
Not enough people own television says to make a late night television series
worthwhile.
Whoa.
The first version of the tonight show starring Steve Allen.
So he was the first 1954 on NBC.
I wonder if that was 11 o'clock at night too.
Hmm.
The show created many modern talk show staples earlier.
Yeah.
Maybe I went to bed earlier back in the day.
Yeah,
I'm probably,
did they go to sleep later?
I thought would think there had been went to bed earlier earlier.
They wouldn't have started electricity,
electricity to watching TV on by candle light farmers and never have to go to
bed.
When it got dark.
They weren't streetlights yet.
So this says that Steve Allen created at all.
It says,
the show created many monitored talk show staples,
including the opening monologue,
celebrity interviews,
audience participation,
comedy bits and musical performances.
By this point,
the federal communications commission had lifted a freeze on new television
stations,
which allowed new stations to pop up across the country and television adoption
soon grew exponentially as a result,
unlike broadly open house,
the tonight show proved to be a resoundingly success,
Huh?
What the fuck was that like?
Pull up a video on the tonight show with Steve Allen from like the earliest you
could find.
No wonder is Byron and got his job.
He's like in the family and island.
Well,
he also found one of those niches where you could kind of sell a show like that.
Like that's what I was kind of saying is that those shows,
it doesn't cost much to make them,
you don't pay the comedians much.
That's all stories written by other people.
Exactly.
They're like,
but I put it together,
I put it in a book and I'm going to make all the money and my names like I'm on
as an author.
I mean that kind of is the exact show.
The whole show is people doing their acts.
You know what I mean?
Literally it's,
you're doing,
it's total ripoff.
It's like if you were sick,
if you were singing songs that you wrote and then they sold the cds,
he be like,
what the fuck?
That's what they're doing.
I mean these people creating these bits,
they have them,
then they go,
uh,
so I understand you've got a two year old kid,
man.
Have a two year old.
It's tough buying them.
It's hey,
hey.
And they do the bit and then I really,
everyone class,
we'll be right back.
Here's some commercials we sold based on this guy's material,
but they all are,
they're selling something
from 1963 of the mall.
He plays the bicycle and his name is Frank Zappa.
Look,
it is Frank Zappa.
Is that Frank Zappa?
Yeah.
The guy on the left.
That is Frank Zappa bicycle.
Yeah.
Wow.
Musician's Union.
Uh,
no,
he's so musical instrument.
Anything more conventional,
perhaps you're tired of lives.
Bass and drums.
Guitar,
Bass,
drums and bicycle.
Bicycle will travel from his base to is your arms.
It was a good time.
Uh,
how did you happen to pick up your first bicycle?
I was discussing this before with some of the people backstage.
I believe that a lot of the people have actually played by cycles from time to
time by side.
They're young.
They take a piece of cardboard and a clothes pin and attach it to the rear wheel
and when it goes around,
it makes that noise and you're playing a biocycle then.
Oh,
I see.
You mean when they pretend they have a little motor and just make it sound like
a motorbike?
Yes,
we've all done that.
What was that?
What you'll do?
You'll make a motorbike noise.
I see a couple of bikes over here.
Perhaps you'd better go over and demonstrate and show them what you do.
What the fuck where people entertained by back then Pa.
I understand you drove a bicycle wheel.
Here we are a French stereo bikes.
So Zappa's playing musical instruments on the bikes,
please.
Uh,
yes.
Well Yours is Kim Dawson style in 1916
there's two clips that were a little earlier,
but you couldn't see what we,
this is after Kennedy was killed as Louis know what you're doing with them.
How crazy is that?
March 4th how long does it kill them to make November microphones that clip onto
your shirt?
He's like holding the microphone back and forth.
I know and it's a stupid looking microphone because dumb.
That microphone looks,
looks like a corn dog.
Like how many years did he go holding the microphone like that?
It'd be sillier than that.
That's what they did.
Yeah.
They had to do back and forth.
We had a hand it back and forth until somebody invented the [inaudible].
Yeah.
They couldn't run to my Crohn's at the same time.
They were low fuses.
Start fires.
Right.
You will be familiar with you going to play violin and ride a bike at the same
time.
The score for the world's greatest center,
the,
he's laughing and who might that be?
Tommy Manville.
Tell us about that.
Are you talking to me?
Okay,
let's skip ahead to the music.
Yeah,
sure.
Did the music for the world's greatest.
Okay,
but that's one of the sounds.
What is this?
Oh,
he's playing the bicycle wires.
Who has like a violin?
Yeah,
sounds fine.
Zappo was weird as fuck.
No,
no.
1963 when he was a buttoned up with a tie and a suit.
He was weird as fuck I got when I first started smoking weed,
that was the first music I would listen to.
Me and my friends would just sit in our car and smoke and listened to Zachary.
I listened to Zappa way before that.
Before I was smoking weed.
I listened to Zappa because I had a friend,
my friend Tommy when I lived,
Shit,
I think I lived in Florida.
My friend.
Yeah,
it was Florida.
My friend,
Tommy's dad was a a real freak.
He was a weird dude and he had a sob.
I remember it was the first guy that I've ever met that had a Saab.
The Saa be one of those cars.
Those guys are freaks.
Well,
back then it was weird like he had the key was on the ground,
like on the floor.
I'm like,
what is this,
this car?
So it was a really old site
because it was the 1970s but a,
he was a fucking gigantic Zappa head.
This guy,
and he would play Zappa for me and for his son.
Interesting music because it's a,
it was really great to listen to with like headphones on because there were so
much noises and sounds going on.
So when,
when I was a young pothead,
that's all I would do is like,
it felt like trimming pot head,
right?
No,
he's not young anymore,
but he's definitely still a potter.
But you know,
like those,
um,
like,
uh,
if you listen to like a old Hendricks and you hear like different sounds going
back and forth across the,
like the field of sound,
like when you have the headphones on and go left and right and right and left as
the coolest shit.
That's what I graduated too after.
Exactly.
Yeah.
That was like what they figured out how to do.
They didn't figure it out how to do that until like the sixties.
Right.
Jamie,
you know,
you're a sound engineer and stuff going back and forth and back and forth,
like the shit like,
uh,
like the like,
you know,
that long pause in whole lot of love where everything gets really weird.
Like they,
it sounds like a normal song and then it's just weird moaning and fuck noises
and strange symbols and stuff for like a minute and a half.
You know that.
Yeah.
There's a lot of stuff that was happening with Zeppelin because of they were
using magnetic tape and storage cause like,
oh get the wet that if the tape was wound too tightly it would get taped bleed
and uh,
five seconds before.
That's kind of how these weird reverb things and weird delays what happens.
So we're like sort of like that.
There'd be a weird screaming,
would it be a previous take on a vocal track because of the way it was stored?
It would end up 30 seconds later,
a minute later on another part of the song and it just sounded so cool.
They just kind of left that kind of stuff.
Then it's really,
instead of recording it over,
doing it all over again,
really accidents would just happen.
They'd leave it.
Man.
Dad's amazing.
I never heard that before.
So it's magnetic bleed,
tape bleed.
Wow.
As to learn some new shit every day.
Kind of like when a movie,
an old movie has all the fucked up films,
you know from Mike seriation and water damage and stuff like that.
Well when they,
whenever they want to show you like an educational film,
a pretend education,
like if it's a movie,
like a horror movie and they show like an educational film for the 1950s it
always has this like crackles and pops and this weird little artifacts and stuff
across the screen.
Not Anymore kids.
Yeah.
Not Anymore though.
Magazine ads from the 50s or so like cute,
aren't they?
They're kind of cute.
Then the fact that people will like dumb kids back then.
It's weird that your parents are like dumb kids.
So simple that a or just like,
wow,
that's so
cute.
You know like vintage advertisements for like Sears or Woolworths or an iron,
you know,
selling to the housewives in the 50s basic basic bitches.
People were just dumb or back then,
yeah,
women were just uneducated.
One was not an educated,
they knew how to do laundry and get grease out of aprons and shit.
Barely knew.
They don't know.
That had a vague apple pie.
Apple pies.
Jesus Christ asked her,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Fake Lemon Meringue Pie.
I think they'd still big paws last I checked.
That's still common to cook.
I do cook.
What do you cook?
Um,
I make a curry carrot soup.
Curry.
Carrot soup.
Yeah.
Have you ever made that super easy to do?
It is,
yeah.
You just,
um,
you just boil some carrots and some onions and garlic and then put it in the
food processor and you got soup.
That seems really,
that doesn't seem like cooking.
It's like you just smash them food together.
You're juicing,
you're juicing.
No,
that's cooking.
Cook.
I also cook.
I also cook lamb cook lamb,
lamb.
I like making um,
orange marmalade.
Glazed lamb.
Lamb is a weird one.
Lambs.
Weird one.
Because it's a baby.
Nobody thinks about that.
I'm going to stop making lamb baby.
You forget that it's a baby.
Nobody ever talks about it like that.
That's why we have a name for it,
you know?
Well,
you don't call a a cow cow.
They call it beef,
you know,
chicken.
Nobody gives a fuck about chickens.
You can call it chicken.
You know,
nobody has it.
Nobody feels bad for chicken.
So you can just call it a chicken.
You don't have to call it some exotic poultry name,
you know,
but like lamb is the name that you have the tiny head chickens.
Right.
The smaller the brain,
the smaller the brain,
the less we care about them I think.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
We didn't,
maybe we didn't have lamb growing up because it was a religious thing.
My mom was against it because it'll land was very biblical.
She would always say,
so I never ate lamb growing up.
Really?
Do you need it now?
I don't like it.
I tasted it.
I don't know if it's just me going,
yeah man,
you just never had it.
No limbs delicious.
If it's prepared.
Right.
I mean,
the idea behind it as that it's just not,
it's not,
doesn't have tough muscle.
Like,
you know,
that moves that I cooked the other day that I had in my,
uh,
my Instagram.
That's not the most tender meat.
Like you have to cook it right.
Otherwise it can be kind of tough and chewy.
It's cause he got to Broil it.
No,
honestly the best way to do it really is doing it.
It's doing is probably the best way to deal with like the co,
the tougher cuts of meat,
like a slow it down for an hour and a half.
No,
no many hours.
You leave it off with five or six hours I'm doing and one like one of those
crockpots you know and all those pressure cookers.
Leave
it on.
It's not that hot and it just stays going all day and it breaks down all the
tissue and anything that's tough.
It makes it so that you could chew through it easy.
It says becomes real,
really,
really tender.
But if you broil it,
I've never had moves.
What does it taste like?
Tastes like a cow.
Fuck the deer a little game.
No.
Yeah,
no,
it's not gave me the board game.
He's a weird word.
What does that not mean?
Usually it means it's just been poorly prepared.
Does it?
Someone either didn't take care of the meat correctly or they let the tarsal
glands leak onto the flesh.
Like when,
uh,
when you,
especially when you get game animals like a deer,
when they're,
when they're being hunted,
a lot of times they're being hunted while they're breeding.
That's when what's called the Rut.
That's when people hunt them,
which is in November,
you know,
in the fall rather.
And they have a gland on their legs called the tarsal glance.
Especially dear.
If you'd get that stuff on the meat,
it'll be funky as fuck.
It stinks.
It smells weird and we'll make the food taste weird.
It'll,
it'll ruin the meat.
Yeah.
The Ken,
another thing can ruin the meat.
It's just letting it sit out too long,
letting it go bad.
That can the or bugs or it get x.
It could get exposed to the Oregon meet the rotting Oregon meet before a while,
while,
while it's too warm,
like that can happen.
You know,
there's a lot of things that can go wrong,
but most of it is preparation.
If you have deer that's prepared,
right?
If you get an animal,
it's taken care of correctly,
butchered correctly.
It doesn't taste game.
It all tastes delicious.
Definitely tastes different.
But they,
as they get older,
they get funk here.
Like you get like a real old buck,
you know?
That's why it's kind of weird that everybody wants to shoot the big old ones
with the giant antlers because those are the ones that kind of tastes like shit.
But you want a young deer for food.
Yeah,
you want a young deer.
But for conservation you kind of want an old deer because the old deer runs off
the young deer and keeps them from breeding.
And maybe the young deer,
maybe it'd be better if we got more than me young genetics into the,
uh,
into the food system there and to the uh,
lifecycle there,
you know?
So,
um,
these deer,
how long do they,
how long,
like how old,
how old is it?
Old Dear old,
old dearly eight years old.
Eight years old is really what his short life,
they have both,
their life is just jumping over barbwire and dodge and coyote.
Unless you,
you leaving one of those areas where now has like a deer sign where you might
get hit by a car.
A good majority of them either freeze to death or starve to death.
That happens a lot.
I wouldn't say majority,
but a good percentage.
The most of them get taken out by predators.
Most of them or cars,
they get hit by cars a lot.
Like the end of the numbers that get killed by hunters.
I wonder what the number is.
Uh,
in some places for sure.
Some places there's hundreds of,
of deaths,
uh,
of deer killed by cars every year,
I think in like Michigan to find out how many deer killed by car accidents in
Michigan.
There's places in this country that are overrun with deer,
like people that live in like Manhattan and go leave those deer alone.
They're beautiful.
A deer crashed through the dorm window in my dorm.
Whoa.
Doing something in there.
No,
it was Easter weekend and this,
we woke up and on a Sunday and there was only,
it was so creepy because everybody went home for Easter weekend except for a few
kids.
So I was one of them.
And we're,
we wake up and go downstairs and there's blood all over the lobby of our dorm.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I like this dear.
Just jumped in.
Yeah,
that should happen.
So my friend Cam,
uh,
some guy died in his neighborhood because he was driving home and the car in
front of him hit a deer current front of him,
hit a deer.
The deer went over the roof of that guy's car and crash through his windshield
and killed him hollering,
shit,
what the fuck?
We need deer proof windows.
You're dealing,
if you're dealing with a big deer,
you're dealing with at least 150 pounds of,
uh,
of bones and meat.
Oh God.
13 look at this.
This number is going to blow you away.
2013 there were 49,205 reported car deer crashes in the state of Michigan.
What the fuck that translates into one car,
dear crash,
every nine minutes.
Wow.
These crashes are at least $130 million a year.
Oh my God.
In Ohio,
I had does whistles on my car.
I'd always make sure that was the first thing I put on my car.
He says,
dear,
whistles on my kids are good,
but they don't always work.
You need one of those goddamn battering ram bumper.
So you ever see those bumpers that they make just for deer in places where
people live when they run into deer so often they actually have bumpers that are
designed to,
they like the front of them has like an angle.
So if they hit the deer,
the deer goes flying off the sides.
Yeah.
Those are,
those are,
those are pretty good ones.
The one the far right.
Not that one,
Jamie.
Not that one.
The one.
Yeah,
look at that one.
Look at that one ahead of the deer.
Stuck in it.
Boom.
That's crazy.
That's fucked up.
But the first semi trucks,
it's a huge problem because obviously they drive the one down there.
Keep going right there.
Right there.
That's it.
See how it's all over the uh,
the top.
It's over the top of the hood and everything as well.
That's just in case.
Uh,
the thing comes up and over the top of the hood that it doesn't crush the hood
and disable the engine.
But most of them are designed so that when it hits the thing,
it bounces them off the left or the right.
It says she was problem in a lot of areas.
Car,
exactly to protect.
The car doesn't,
but the deer gets mangled in there.
At least you still have to stop.
You stopped,
you pull it out.
What do you buy your business?
Yeah.
Do you have to do that or is there,
somebody could call it a day that,
cause I'm not going to want to call a tow truck company.
I'm sure he could call someone to do it.
If you paid them,
I'm sure someone would do it,
but it's not that hard.
You just drive off.
But if you're trying to get Wifi and get on craigslist,
looking for somebody to remove deer from Lane Dashboard,
I'm on 95 exit 18.
I think the people that don't live anywhere around those animals would never
imagine that there's 49,000 car accidents a year in a fucking state where cars
had deer.
But if you're ever around Michigan,
you would know this should be Trump's new platform.
Let's lower the amount of crashes caused by deer.
You know,
he needs,
he needs to focus on something else right now.
Number one,
why does he need to focus on anything?
You know what it seems to me,
I don't know anything about politics,
but what it seems to me on the outside not knowing anything about it,
it seems to me like everybody else is laying back there waiting and they're
letting Donald just Jizz just letting Donald get out there and fucking jerk off
and make all this noise.
No one's no other.
Republican's are being loud like Jeb Bush is being very quiet.
No one's opposing him.
Let him act like a fool.
Chris Christie,
that guy,
he goes on the news and all he does is talk about pot.
You know,
if you're,
if you're enjoying what he's trying to do is trying to not be president.
I think that slob has like some crazy criminal fucking skeletons in his closet
from shit that he did in New Jersey that's completely not kosher.
And he just like,
if he becomes president,
all that Shit's going to leak out.
So I think he's trying to ruin it now by like saying if you're smoking pot,
Colorado,
enjoy it now because when I'm president,
all that stuff he's saying like,
why would you say stuff like that?
You know what popular opinion is popular opinion is Colorado's making millions
of dollars a year in tax revenue.
They have the lowest incidence of drunk driving they've ever reported.
They have lower incidents then uh,
in violent crime they've had in a long fucking time.
And a lot of this is attributed to marijuana.
So a rational fucking person looking at that,
we'll say,
well look,
it's good money for the state.
Even if you're conservative,
what do you want?
You want more tax revenue so we can hire more cops,
more fire,
more fire people,
more more teachers.
That's like a,
what a conservative person would look at it.
Like,
this is a smart way to do it cause it's fiscally prudent.
But know that Slob in my state fucking bagels fallen out of his face.
Who could run for president?
There should be a weight limit.
No,
because you could be a giant.
It'd be awesome.
Like what if you're like some seven foot two to waste 500 pounds.
Okay.
How about your proportionate body fat percentage?
We would never let that happen.
If there was a seven foot two dude with a giant fucking fire hydrant dick and he
wanted to be president and he was smart in every way,
we'd be like,
hm,
how do we,
how do we know his Dick was that?
Every time he talks Jon Hamm photo shoot,
he just stands there and he's got this giant wad in his pants and everybody's
like,
I think,
I mean it's got to look at the signs of them and they just assume they guys have
big dicks.
Someone knows more than we do.
Oh,
is that your ratio?
I mean,
I'd be noticed.
I don't know.
I know.
I'm just guessing
because it just,
it is what it,
it just wouldn't,
it wouldn't,
you know,
cause they already have the height so it just wouldn't be fair for them to have
a big Dick and hike and get the girls.
So you think the world's fair
giant heads and huge teeth and antelopes on of guns.
This is not a fair world we're living in.
How dare you?
It doesn't make any sense.
I've seen short guys with big Dicks,
so I just assumed that tall guys must have small dicks.
Well that's good math.
You should probably,
she probably worked for the governor then.
See I would think everything is proportional to most parts of your big tall guy
with big,
big feet.
You probably have a bigger dick than a normal guy.
You're not thinking that well that doesn't make any sense
to you.
It makes sense.
As long as it makes sense to you.
See that means that you have fucked a very couple of big tall guys and both of
them,
they're Dixon weren't as big as you wanted and you're projecting it on.
I saw a tall guy with a small penis one time.
One time.
One time I saw a Chinese black girlfriend,
so I'm basing all Chinese dudes date black girls.
I get what you're saying.
I think all Asian girls have small vaginas like,
like length wise.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a actual stereotype.
It's like black eyes having big dicks.
That's a start.
Like you're not going out on a limb there,
but giant dudes have little dicks.
That's,
that doesn't make sense.
That's going on on
that day.
A little dicks.
How ironic.
Oh my God,
that is so ridiculous.
I love being stupid.
How long are you going to be in La for?
Till Saturday.
You got gigs on here.
What are you doing?
This is going on right now.
What is the Common Union Comedy Club?
Have you heard of it?
Do you have black comedy that you do specifically for these African American
rooms or does it like you just do your own act?
Do do a lot of these African American rooms,
African American,
urban,
politically correct.
I
black rooms in New York.
Why do you do a lot of them?
To just enjoy it because
they're so fun.
They're so fun.
Yeah,
it's,
it's just you feel like you're just like riding waves of laughter,
you know,
nonstop.
Like they just laugh harder.
They definitely do.
But they also,
they get bored of you quick,
which is good because it just makes you better.
You know,
Chris Rock said that once that he did a show with Martin Lawrence and then he
realized that he had been doing too many white rooms.
He's like white people or to patient.
Like he did a black show with Martin Lawrence and Martin Lawrence killed and he
had to go on after Martin Lawrence and he was like,
Oh snap shit.
I better get back to the black room because Martin Lawrence in the 1990s fucking
monster.
A lot of people know him.
He's one of those guys ever seen him.
He's one of those guys,
a lot of people,
they,
they sleep on him now because he kinda got a little bit,
he had some,
some issues with mental health and the law.
Remember there was like,
he was running around with a wetsuit on and yelling at people or something.
Remember that?
It was like d hydrated.
They were saying he was dehydrated and saying a bunch of nutty shit and they
pulled them in for some sort of,
uh,
you know,
they,
they did ran some tests on him.
They wanted to find out what the hell's wrong with him.
And then he kind of faded off and did some movies,
but he kind of stopped doing stand up until recently.
Yeah.
I forgot all about him.
Just started doing it again though.
I remember he was at the store a few weeks ago.
Oh,
cool.
Yeah,
he was like doing the main room.
I didn't get a chance to see it though,
but uh,
I heard it was good.
He was a fucking awesome when I was,
when I was starting out though in the 90s.
I used to have to go on after him at the comedy store.
Oh my God.
Hey Dick.
Going on after him.
I ate dick when I went on after him during this era,
during the you so crazy era.
I love that.
In extremely funny film where he got,
he's one of those guys that got banned from MTV too,
didn't he?
He get banned for some of the things that he said.
He was like,
it's something like made jokes about tampons or something like that and that was
Kurt Loder was liking Knopf nothing when they banned dice clay.
Remember the band dice clay for Di Deuce jokes?
Yeah,
enough.
Now they have whole episodes on tampons on MTV course they do Kurt Loder.
Where's he at?
I don't know.
Just try to be respectable record store guy.
You know those guys that were like the,
the Djs of,
they were like the cool record store clerks.
You know,
they kind of knew what was good and what was not going to like cool Dj guys.
You know that like actually could pick and choose the music they liked.
Like the old days when I used to listen to radio when I was a kid,
Djs were stars because it,
no a Dj is the first famous person I met will know a Dj like,
like a radio,
like the oldies channel Guy.
Who was the first one you met?
It was dick beyond a,
and he,
he was the DJ for the Chicago oldies radio station.
He's a famous guy.
Well to me he was famous.
He was famous like on the air in Chicago.
Yeah.
Like he was like Dick beyond these forgotten the oldies.
Oh,
that's funny.
That's him.
There's Dick.
Yeah.
I went to a mattress store to meet Dixie.
Anandi does look exactly example.
That's hilarious.
It was a lot older than that.
Well that was drawn before cameras were invented.
Yeah.
They um,
they used to be able to pick the music.
So those guys were the cool guys like they used to play because I was like,
I love everything.
He pigs,
you know,
Sam Cooke and the beach boys and you know,
the carpenters.
I thought it was awesome and I was,
I used to really play records.
You don't at least actually play the record.
There was at one point in time,
the DJ was the guy laying the needle down.
Think about that.
They used to pick the records here.
Mistakes probably.
Oh yeah,
I'm sure a lot Buhler dude.
When I was a kid,
you would listen to the radio and you'd hear a fucking record skip.
It would happen all the time.
It would happen all the time,
like once every couple months or something like that.
Someone will be playing whole lot of love or whatever and hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
Hello.
And no one would catch it for like a minute or so.
And you would be like working construction cycle.
What the fuck?
Jesus Christ get it right.
You fucks yelling at them.
And then finally someone would correct it when I'm like a bathroom break and
just let the record like repeat for like three minutes maybe.
Probably cigarettes.
They'd probably say,
well they probably smoking cigarettes in the billings back though.
Yeah,
totally.
And the buildings.
Remember Greg Fitzsimmons telling about his parents smoking cigarettes in the
house in the middle of the winter,
all the windows rolled up and solid tight and he's just living as a little kid
in this house filled with chain smokers.
That's how my,
my best friend growing up,
his parents and I just stayed at his house every single day.
And in the cars they would have the windows rolled up in the cars during rain.
That's the thing about those talk shows too.
They all used to smoke cigarettes on the talk show.
They'd all be sitting there like Johnny Carson used to smoke cigarettes.
See if you can find a video of that.
Cause it's so weird to watch Johnny Carson Smoking cigarettes on the tonight
show and be like guess would be there and he would have an ash tray right there
and they would just now when we'd is legalized in all 50 states,
then we'll just be smoking weed on the tonight show.
No,
because you hotbox people you know like that Gig and Toronto didn't wear a mask.
You know,
how about you don't smoke weed in front of you?
I might just have an edible or smoke outside or like some host will just be
smoking weed.
Look at you.
Imagine if you were in a bar and the other people drinking got you drunk,
that'd be fucked.
Right.
That's what it's like with weed.
The other people getting high literally get you high,
like secondhand highs.
Real is it?
Like,
I always wondered,
cause I swear to God I read something once where they said no,
once it's in your mouth,
it's totally everything that you're blowing out is absorbed,
uh,
from weed.
That's not true.
It's not.
No,
definitely not that.
You know,
it's proof positive that God damn Toronto Room.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's the only reason I believe it.
The people have gone up that were stone cold sober and they got hot box and that
Toronto Room people been in his,
this podcast studio
and got hotbox.
I think [inaudible] got hot box.
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure if Greg got hotbox too.
Yeah.
You get hotbox to hotbox is real.
Anybody that says nodded you.
You haven't done any tests.
They're liars.
We always used to clam bake growing up.
We believed it growing up.
I think Ed Mcmahon was ass drunk.
Jake Elrich senior on the tonight show with Johnny Carson play this.
We hear these guys talking back then look at Johnny.
The amendment.
Look at this and there some time ago was a book put out by United States and
Canada.
Most all of the book,
both smoking and with the committee hearing Rehab and it was only one chapter in
the book was worth considering and then was way he said
[inaudible]
right under the fifth amendment.
The Fifth Amendment is not good law if we are to be called criminals because we
use it and then let you take it out of the constitution.
Let's get rid of it.
What's the Fifth Amendment?
Recall history of the reading of history right there.
Any guesses?
Some difficulties with the,
with Greg
proceedings where they fall down,
no person shall be held to answer for a capital or otherwise infamous crime and
less on the present or indictment of a grand jury against them.
Still that no person,
a present moment or indictment of a grand jury except in cases are rising in the
land or naval forces or militia.
Huh?
I'm not sure I have a good one.
Pleading the fifth means you're not supposed to talk,
right?
You plead the fifth you don't have to talk.
That's what it is.
It protects the person against being compelled to a witness stand.
Okay.
Himself or herself in a criminal case.
How weird is that that we have a law like that?
Like yeah,
it was that like if you're a gent,
non gender specific person.
Oh,
but he's uh,
he's still a dude.
He was banging that check.
Right.
Maybe that's why she was sticking around.
Maybe it was a tentacle.
That's why she came back.
See if he came back to life again.
Bring that Dick back.
I want a social security number for Jeffrey Lash.
What a weird thing it is that you can say,
I don't want to testify like Esther,
you know,
uh,
we caught you with a kilo of cocaine and you got a gun and uh,
how do you plead?
I plead the fifth.
You don't have to talk.
And they,
then they decide whether or not you're guilty.
Look at what a great country we live in.
Just seems a very bizarre,
that seems very bizarre that you shouldn't have to
plead the fifth.
You can because you kind of have the court of your own life.
It's just,
it's not going to fly.
Most people,
not most people
are going to go,
they're going to bang that malate order.
Ordering the court.
Who's fucking underwear is this again?
There's no one put a gun to your head.
There's no fifth in this house.
Yeah,
plead the fifth.
That's a weird thing to be able to do.
Like if you got caught with a dead body,
you don't have to talk and then they decide whether or not you're guilty.
Ever really hold up in court course.
Those fifth,
fifth a productive
Dave Chappelle.
Yeah.
It holds up in court.
Yeah,
it's,
that's a,
that's an amendment to the constitution.
I don't know if they,
you can be compelled to testify.
I don't.
There's a,
there are times we can be compelled to answer.
I don't know.
No,
you can just sit there and say nothing and be put in a whole,
yeah,
I guess.
All right.
They can't force you to talk Farris who have just written,
plead the fifth to every question that they've asked.
I'm sure.
Well that's why like when should night gets arrested,
he falls down,
falls down,
pretends he's blacking out.
Like that's what he does.
Like whenever they like say like he's getting sentenced to bill bales,
10 million bucks collapses like so they have to take him out of there and then
they have to take him to the infirmary and they have to breathing hard.
I think it's better to be in medical care than it is to be in the cell.
So if you're smart,
every time they sentence,
you just fucking have a seizure nose.
You don't have to even show them.
Just fall down.
Just I can't breathe.
I can't just fall down.
Just fall down and you just say you're weak.
I'm blocking out.
They can't prove you're not blacking out.
So they have to take you to the doctor and take care of you.
Oh,
what did
great idea.
I love falling down.
He's a dude,
has been around the block,
love falling down.
I read a book on how to prevent osteoporosis and there's an entire chapter on
how not to fall down.
What?
Yeah,
that because US oil,
they say,
what's the advice?
They say a walk slowly and
your doctor talk to her ass hole.
Whenever there's handrails,
hold on to the hand rails.
And if there's no handrail hold onto the wall or a person.
Why were you reading this?
Because I like reading on how to be healthy.
It's all right.
I like,
I like being able to prevent the season,
the idea that it's just like walk slowly.
Oh okay.
I was running around and I was
like if I had,
if I had a choice between buying a house with stairs and buying a house with no
stairs,
I would,
because I've read that book and because I know that,
you know,
ask,
do you like,
like you know,
falling down does weaken your bones.
I would rather buy crest.
Esther,
how have you made it so far?
That's seriously.
How have you made it this far in life,
this kind of logic?
How are you here?
Fully dressed.
Fed.
You have a car?
No,
for real.
It makes it wouldn't have stairs.
I've got it figured I'm going to walk
away from tall guys because they might have little to the probability of you
falling if you live in a just a one level house is lower.
So
true.
Cause a lot of times people don't fall downstairs all the time.
People fall in the kitchen,
they fall getting out of the tub.
That's a big one.
Stairs getting out of town.
Almost fall in my tub.
But like every time I get in it
Mike,
oh shit.
I must Darren friend who fell in her tub.
She broke ribs.
Shit.
Yeah,
you can get fucked up and breaking ribs is our bomber.
You ever broken a rib now?
I haven't broken anything.
I broke,
I broke ribs at least at least two times.
I think more.
I think I broken a more,
but I've also broken the cartilage in between the ribs at least six or seven
times.
Yes.
What mostly martial arts people were punching you?
Kicking him.
Kicking you is a big one.
Wow.
The set that what happens is the rebs even if the ribs,
the ribs,
even if the ribs don't break,
what happens is you get kicked really hard and the separate,
so the,
the,
the cartilage in between the ribs breaks and so then it pops like when you
breathe,
you could feel it moving and you have to wait till that bitch stops moving and
you have to wait till it to heal up.
So it's months and months and months where you can do anything when you smoke
weed.
This is before I was smoking weed.
Oh.
So,
but I would imagine you could smoke weed but it's going to fucking hurt anytime
you do that,
it's going to hurt.
Like anything we expand that same aisle,
ribs,
any movement.
Like that was a thing like Josie Aldo,
one of the UFC fighters had a pullout of his title five cause he got a broken
rib.
And uh,
they were saying,
well he's going to try to rest and try to heal up,
but you can't even,
you can't even exercise.
Like he would gain weight.
You'd never be able to make weight.
You can't do any kind of training and if anybody hits you in that rib again,
you're fucked.
Like it's,
it's super dangerous.
Like the rib can actually break loose and go into your organs.
It's like the whole design of that thing is a cage around your internal organs,
but it's pliable.
So you rather get paid in the ribs or get a concussion and brighten the ribs all
day.
100%.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would rather have the pain.
The pain of getting a broken rib.
I mean,
you'd still do damage to your organs and shit,
but damage to your head is a totally different ballgame.
Damage to your head is very fucking day.
I've had damage to my head and no,
how recently,
right before they show,
but I can't remember.
No.
Like a few years ago I had a concussion.
Really?
What happened?
I got mugged in New York.
No Shit.
Yeah.
What happened?
Um,
I was walking to a show and I blame this purse that I bought.
I bought like a vintage beautiful coach purse and that was like my first fancy
purse,
you know,
some walking to his show.
And I have this purse and all of a sudden I'm just knocked out.
Like I don't remember what happened and I never saw who hate me,
but somebody hit me on the head and I was just like on the ground.
Oh yeah,
it,
it was in Bushwick on like near the grand street.
L Stop.
What is Bush?
That Brooklyn is Brooklyn and yeah,
it's like past Williamsburg.
Yeah.
It's like where are all these?
Like artists are building lofts and you know,
because it has studios.
Yeah.
And there's a bunch of art studios and stuff there,
but it's still like,
you know,
a tough neighborhood.
So there was like nobody on the street because it was like a Sunday at like 6:00
PM or something.
And so you have no idea what happened?
Yeah.
I never saw you call the police.
No,
I woke up in some lady's apartment and the police were already there and it was
like a super seventies apartment and I was like looking at them,
I didn't know where I,
you know what I mean?
It was like my first time blacking out.
So I just like was looking at them like,
who are you?
Why,
what am I doing?
Like I felt like I was in the twilight zone.
Where did you get hit?
You know?
Um,
I had a black eye,
so probably like up here somewhere.
Wow.
Yeah.
Nobody saw it.
This lady heard me scream and called the cops.
She screamed.
I screamed.
Yeah.
Huh.
And they ran off and my purse was still there.
Yeah,
he got scared probably cause I screamed really loud.
Yeah.
So you don't remember screaming?
You don't remember anything?
You don't know?
I don't remember screaming.
You must have been probably fighting with them to try to keep your purse and
then you got hit because if he got knocked out you wouldn't feel a scream after
you got knocked out.
Right?
Maybe,
but I don't remember anything.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's fucked.
When did this happen?
Um,
like maybe four or five years ago.
Five years ago.
So God damn scary to someone over a purse.
I mean,
I'm assuming it was a purse,
you know,
but who knows what they,
why they were doing it.
Some,
like they say that there's like a,
a knockout game,
you know,
where people just go around like knocking people out for fun.
I've seen that.
That might've been Nicole about the time period where that was going on also.
Yeah.
So I don't know if that's,
and there was no video of it,
you know,
it was just a residential block,
so it's horrible.
Yeah.
How long did it take before you recovered?
A few months.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
It happened like,
like I would like want to go to comedy shows,
but I didn't want to like show up with a black eye,
you know?
So I just like stayed home.
But what about your head?
Um,
you know,
the cops just said I was really lucky.
They just kept saying that like nothing else happened to me,
you know,
so I felt fine because I didn't,
I didn't,
I never saw anybody coming after me with like a poll or,
you know what I mean?
Like,
so you just woke up,
it,
it wasn't so traumatizing because I never remembered what happened.
Did you always feel
weird about looking around now while you're walking after that?
Yeah.
Now I got a body guard,
you know,
traveling for you.
Looking at Brian,
if that's your bodyguard.
No,
you gotta tell me specifically what you're planning on doing with them.
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
I'm super like careful or like I'll have somebody walk with me or something,
you know?
Right,
right.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a dark world out there sometimes.
Sometimes people are fucking evil is shit.
The fact that someone could just hit a little tiny girl like you.
What do you weigh?
A hundred pounds.
100 something.
101 10 she's in here?
Yeah,
Raul Muscle.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
It's so fun.
Top.
But someone could do that.
Then get hit you,
knock you out and just leave you on the side of the road and that's how people
die like that.
Man.
People die like that all the time.
Kevin James was working as a bouncer and this a nightclub in Long Island and the
guy who was working with kill the guy accidentally who's a bouncer as well.
There's something going on.
Drunks,
craziness,
punch.
Some guy,
guy fell down,
unconscious bangs his head off the ground dead.
That's what happened.
You never know.
He's like,
you have to hold back so many punches.
Like you want to punch somebody but you never know they could die.
Well you seem,
the problem is people see movies.
People get like pistol whipped wack and they fall down and you wake up.
Ah,
what happened?
And they,
they could still Duke it out and Bra.
Like if somebody hits you in the back of the head with a metal hammer,
which is essentially what a hammer is.
W uh,
a gun is rather so he pistol whipped you,
you're fucked.
Like you're fucked for many months.
You might not ever be the same again.
My friend got hit in the head,
Ryan Parsons,
you met Ryan.
He got hit in the head with a golf ball.
He was fucked up for six months.
Somebody hit a line drive,
hit him right in the head.
He went down screaming in agony,
blacked in and out of consciousness.
Wasn't the same for six months,
couldn't go outside,
couldn't see the sun.
Sunlight would kill him.
It would give him piercing headaches.
Oh,
loud sounds couldn't read.
Fuck man.
Wow.
Yeah.
Shit.
Yeah,
no good.
We got a guy on yesterday was talking about his friend who was in her forties.
Um,
my friend curic,
his friend was in her forties and she was doing a street luge.
You know what it is?
It's kind of like,
you know,
you're like a Bob sled but on the street and you're no like,
like,
you know,
you're lying down on a skateboard or something like that.
And she wiped out,
banged her head really hard and she was fucked.
Just fucked and like pretty much permanently.
Permanently fucked.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They told her to not read,
not talk to people.
Don't do an after six months.
They said you can get a pet chicken.
Don't get a cat or a dog cause her to interactive
like literally like the day,
like her brain's sewn.
Dogs are supposed to help.
Like,
you know,
they help some things.
The dog shitting all over your carpet.
You've got a headache.
You like cheese,
somebody's taking care of the dog.
Yeah.
You'd have to have someone like doing everything,
cleaning after the dog,
all that jazz.
Wow.
I met a woman at one of my shows in Brooklyn.
She had no hands or feet.
What happened to her?
Well,
she came up to me after the show and she like wanted to like give me a hug.
She was like,
you're so funny.
And she had like these stubs and she said,
you remind me of the girls who did my nails when I had hands.
And I was like,
whoa.
Then like
I said,
why so much to take table was like racism,
Korea,
Vietnamese,
what the fuck?
Oh,
I was like,
I was thinking like I want to bring it up if I just met her any other way.
Right.
But since she brought up her hands,
I was like,
what happened to your hands?
And she said that she had um,
something wrong with her appendix went to the hospital and the doctor put the
wrong name,
like mixed up her charts and they amputated her hands and her feet
when she was only supposed to get her appendix taken out or something.
Very minor.
Yeah.
And then a few weeks after that comedy show where I met her,
I saw on the front page of the paper in New York,
it said so and so so-and-so,
whatever her name was,
I forgot her name.
Uh,
given $14 million or whatever,
you know,
like the settlement for your hands and your feet.
I forget how much it was,
but no hand jobs maybe longer.
And I met her boyfriend.
All can imagine dating that happening to your girlfriend and you're like,
ah,
yeah,
I'll stick around with it.
Right.
I asked him,
I said,
how long have you guys been together?
He was like a year when that happened.
Wow.
I was like,
well I'm man,
you're such a good guy.
You know,
she can't even like wipe her ass
or maybe he went to the fucking hospital and switch to put things on here.
She is the founder.
All right there.
But you know why she was so,
let's just so bizarre.
She was so happy that like,
you know,
you wonder like how that,
how she can be happy.
But she was so like,
she was in such a good mood.
Like she was just like loving the comedy show.
She was so appreciative and like she was having a great time.
Wow.
And I was like,
you know,
there's no reason that anybody should have to commit suicide.
Like,
you know,
this woman doesn't even have hands and she's happy.
I see your point in that regard.
But I think people commit suicide because of mental issues.
I think that the mind,
the depression that people go through,
some people go through some fucking unbearable depression.
It's just,
I don't understand it.
I don't know it.
But I know people have gone through it and there's something that happens to the
human mind when the serotonin dopamine levels are,
or you just don't
want to be alive.
You just would rather shut the lights off.
I get it.
And once you think that you don't want to be alive,
that just takes over and everything's just doomed from then on.
Yeah.
My friends going through it right now and I was trying to talk to him the other
day and it's just like you can't,
no matter what you say,
it's not going to change his mind of how horrible everything is in its place.
That you could just like show them pictures of like happier times.
Like remember when we went to the waterpark,
right.
And haven't worked and have it work or you know,
show them memories of like,
you wish you could just show them videos of,
you know,
happier times that they've had.
Yeah.
There's so many variables too.
There's like,
your life could be sucky and there's no end in sight.
There's no light at the end of the tunnel.
Or it could be chemical and your life is Saki or it could be a series of sad
things that have happened to you and failures or losing jobs or you know,
being depressed and unemployable or,
you know,
there's a lot of things that people just do,
a series of events take place and then they reach a point where they feel like
it's never gonna get any better and they just don't want to play anymore.
They just don't want to do it anymore.
There's a comedian who saved a guy jumping off the bridge,
the George Washington bridge,
like a huge comedian.
He like held him,
Oh my God,
for like hours or something goes really wrong.
I couldn't,
I don't think you could hold him for hours,
but maybe not for hours,
but he was like a complete hero that day.
Totally got jumped the next day was stupid.
I'm doing right.
How's your arm sore?
There's people that does don't want to be here anymore.
They're going to die eventually.
You know?
That's what's really fucked up.
It's like we want them to stay alive.
We want to save them,
but we also know that this is a temporary ride and they're hating this ride.
This ride sucks for them.
Yeah.
And so it's hard to tell them,
hey man,
stick around for what?
What am I sticking around for so they can keep doing this for another 30 years
and then what?
And then it's over.
They going to talk to,
you know,
people just like people have become hermits and they don't want to leave their
house and you know,
like our society allows it to happen because like the way it's built nowadays
with so many conveniences,
like you could just get food delivered,
you can get anything delivered to your house.
I had all of Guardian and you don't have a reason to like leave your house and
you could just let it pile up and become a mess.
Livers.
No,
but there's apps now like she said,
like we'll deliver anything.
So,
oh yeah,
go through the APP,
order it in like 40 minutes.
I had all of you could just be addicted to internet porn and just never leave
your house.
Let's
do that as well.
There's a lot of people that do that.
There's a guy that I know that a,
he's like a professor I'm going to get him on eventually,
but he thinks there's nothing wrong with being addicted to porn.
He said the way he equates as being addicted to porn is like being addicted to
sports or being addicted to games or playing videos.
Like he's like,
it's just you're,
you're enjoying something.
Like everybody has this bad idea in their head that like the obsession about
porn is so awful.
Whereas like the obsession about video games just
at the most unfortunate or you know,
a waste of time and had sex with a real life human being in years.
How do you know?
Maybe I think he's just a professor.
I'm not necessarily think,
I don't necessarily think he's talking about himself.
I think he's trying to make
some sort of a rational argument for why we have this unusual attitude about sex
that we don't apply to everything else.
Like,
if someone really loves cars,
like say if you're like a guy like loves vintage cars and you just want like
there's,
there's people,
like I looked at this house,
uh,
that was for sale on there was in the Pacific northwest and it was the guy was a
Ferrari fan.
Like you love Ferrari's,
so you had Ferrari design,
his kitchen,
he's like got a Ferrari kitchen.
And then he had a glass wall from his living room to this enormous garage that
was filled with Ferrari's.
And this guy was just obsessed with Ferrari.
He's,
he's just a rich guy who loved and he had old ones and he had new ones and he
had like vintage ones and this guy was just obsessed.
He had Ferrari books and magazines.
But if that was porn,
you'd think he's a creep.
Right.
You know,
if it's cars,
like wow,
he's got a fucking loves Ferraris,
you don't get it.
But he is,
you don't judge them.
You Go,
well I guess he just really likes Ferrari's,
whatever.
He's got money,
who cares?
But if you went over his house and it's all just blow up dolls and dildos
so far.
She's house.
Yeah,
it is judge his house.
He's like,
if you need a place to stay,
let me know.
Do you get pregnant?
Just walking through the door and you know she's placed,
but you know what I'm saying?
It's like why?
Why do we get,
I think it's because we have weird attitudes about sex and we also have the
attitude that porn,
at least some of it dehumanizes women like porn.
At least some of it makes you look at women like they're an object and not an
equal,
not a person.
Just something to fuck.
That's why they have a hard time meeting a real live woman because they've been
desensitized to it so much.
They want to treat a woman like that.
The minute they meet her,
you know,
have time.
He doesn't like,
they don't have the time to get to know you.
They don't have the patience to get to.
They're just like sitting there on a date probably thinking,
why isn't she taking her clothes off and licking my balls?
You know?
That's what everybody thinks by the way.
They just keep it to themselves.
Yeah,
definitely.
Well,
those scenarios too.
It's just like what we were talking about earlier,
kind of any scenario that you depict in a movie that become like the lion king
or Cimbar and that shit,
it becomes the Yogi bear.
It becomes like how you start thinking of bears.
Well,
if you watched too many movies where girls just call a plumber and starts
sucking his Dick,
you just assume that this is how people operate and behave the same way.
You assume Yogi bear is going to try to take your picnic basket and not eat your
kids.
You know,
we have these weird images in our head because of the media and porn.
As much as it doesn't seem like it's the media.
Absolutely.
100% is it's you're watching,
my college boyfriend was addicted to porn.
Why?
I think that because um,
I thought his name was John for the longest time and then everybody,
his dorm floor was like,
Yo,
his porno John here.
And I was like,
what the fuck is Bordeaux John?
They're like,
well there's two Johns on her floor.
These porno John.
Yeah cause he like porno cause he was like,
he had the most porn out of everybody on his floor.
Maybe he's just really good at collecting shit.
I mean,
I hope so.
I hope so now.
Yeah,
no,
he was like regular.
I was freaking than him.
Yeah,
because like,
I dunno,
I think when you're young you just like sometimes have sex and you don't care
about the other people's feelings.
You know,
after he came I would keep going and he would be like,
I'm trying to do my homework.
Do you mind?
You need to find a better dude.
That's what every guy wants.
Every guy wants to grow,
wants to have sex all the time.
So he wasn't that much of a freak.
They named him Porno John,
but it could be
eaten off like crazy white
woman.
Then once he came on,
so I'm done.
I'm fucking exhausted.
Cause he already ran five marathons that day,
you know?
So running up a flight of stairs was exhausting for a normal person running up a
flight of stairs is pretty commonplace.
Right.
Porno John,
he just been beaten off into a couple day
time.
So why would you care if he watched porn?
Brainwashed by all these
romantic comedies or magazines or whatever.
Do Romantic comedies get mad if they're romantic comedies where a woman gets mad
if a guy's using porn?
Yeah,
except some of the hipper ones.
Like if he's watching porn that he must not want me and I would like
fun to watch.
I don't care if he watches girls get mad at you.
Yeah.
Like she,
she would get,
I had girls get mad at me that if I followed porn people on Instagram,
Twitter to the point of like,
why I'm not doing it for you type thing.
Like it got so bad where I wasn't allowed to do porn or even have photos of
women I as wallpapers or anything like that.
I think when I was younger I was taught to like think that it's,
you know,
you're just supposed to take it personal if personally,
if you don't,
if he's watching porn,
he,
you must not be enough or something,
you know,
from your friends or was it from probably from growing up in the Midwest.
That's right.
Chicago sort of morals like Chicago is still the Midwest,
even though it's a big city,
it's just,
it's still like frowned upon
crazy behavior,
you know?
So I was like,
let me get out of here.
You guys suck.
I love Chicago.
But I see what you're saying.
I think those spots in the middle of the country,
you know,
there's a lot of,
there's a lot of hold overthinking a certain of change though,
isn't it?
This is trying to change all across the country.
People becoming more and more openminded.
Wouldn't you imagine that?
Well,
when I moved here Joe,
like you would talk about masturbating all the time and I remember one time
you're talking about how you were math,
you masturbated the other day to something.
And I was like,
I can't believe he's telling me this right now.
I hope loud.
Like I was so like,
like shy about it matters.
Not Him like recently,
no,
this is like 13 years ago.
He started working for me about 13 years ago ago.
Right.
Yeah.
That's cool.
But that's how it changed.
It is in the Midwest though.
Like talking about poop out loud.
No,
that's why Brian seems childlike because really he's experiencing this for the
first time.
Yeah.
Whereas like most people,
by the time,
by the time they're 10 years old or actually 10 yes.
Came here as an infant,
30 year old.
That's true.
But you got to agree,
right?
Like if,
if you know,
growing up in Chicago,
you don't want to openly talk about masturbation and in front of people.
Right.
I would like xerox copy,
like sex,
sex cartoons and put them in my planner and like sex cartoon,
you know,
like,
yeah.
Like there was like a joke book or you know there's like a cartoon book with sex
jokes that I thought was funny and it was like,
you know,
a fly with a big Dick or something and you know,
it will look like,
you know what his,
I was like really,
you know,
hastily made drawings that just have like one word or one phrase or something.
Right.
With like,
you know,
somebody holding a [inaudible],
you know?
And I would just like think those were funny and I would spread rumors in my
school about like sex ed,
cause that was always like,
Ooh,
having sex ed,
you know,
we're in sixth grade and so I'd be like,
so our class went first insect set,
so the,
the afternoon class was like,
oh what was it like?
And I was like,
well Mrs Elmore and Mr. Reynolds got naked and had sex.
They were like,
I would like start rumors like that,
you know,
when people believed me.
Is that how you became a comic?
Yeah.
By just being inappropriate,
but being funny in school,
being fine in school and then like people didn't expect it.
You're,
you're this small,
cute girl and you're saying,
yeah,
these dirty things.
Well,
and the teacher like,
so I would never get in trouble either because I would always just find
somebody,
somebody who looked like red van and blame it on him,
you know,
good move and be like,
I didn't want to do that.
That's a good move and changed the whole schedule.
Yeah.
Your bully.
It's funny though.
I am a bully.
How you get in fights a lot though?
I don't you,
um,
physical fights.
I mean maybe not physical.
You get in fights.
No,
I don't get in fights.
No.
What are you talking about?
Where are you making this up?
Fairly or she said something about,
uh,
punching.
Uh,
you said something about it,
you never know when to stop punching.
And I thought
you were talking personally.
I think I'm just going to ask you if you had kids,
do you as an anybody out there listening you,
he thought I met me.
Oh,
you never know when to stop punching.
What you want to be careful who you punch [inaudible] because you know they
might crack their head open and die soon.
That she got a lot of fights because of that.
Well No,
cause she,
she said something like,
uh,
you,
you never know when to stop pumps punching it and how she said it,
she says like you like as in like,
you know,
you never know when to stop punching.
I was thinking like,
Oh
do you follow,
are you falling when he's saying no?
Why does he think that you get in fights to get in arguments with people or
something?
I understand why he would think that.
Why do you,
are you feisty?
Is that what this is?
I mean I have been,
but I'm not like that's not my normal state.
You know,
she doesn't seem like someone gets it.
No,
it was just how she said it earlier.
It's always just trying to sound like I know how to finance it cause you guys
talk about MMA
so,
oh yeah,
that's what we do.
So did you fly down here just to hang out and do some shows?
How many days you down here for till Saturday?
Thinking about moving to California St Fuck Miami.
I think you are right.
I love it here.
Right?
Most comedy community do.
She'd come last night at the comedy store was off the fucking Hook last night.
Oh,
the bros powder and the original round,
the original room was sold out.
It was mobbed.
It was amazing.
And then upstairs,
a roast battle was crazy packed and a fucking hilarious.
Who was the kid that went on first?
The Guy,
the guy who won the roast battle,
the blonde guy with the glasses.
Find Jamie.
Find that dude,
that guy was fucking money.
It's too,
too crowded.
Even go in there and watch it.
So like I didn't get to see any of the,
uh,
who organizes,
who's going to battle?
Who?
That's a good question.
I don't know the answer to that.
But Brian Moses is the host and it's a,
it's a perfect length show cause it happens late at night.
Have,
it's like 1145 and it only lasts like an hour.
It's like,
it's,
and it's over,
you know,
but one o'clock in the morning,
everybody's going home.
It's perfect.
It's monstrously fun.
Jeff.
Yeah.
Jeff sewing.
God.
Damn,
that dude's funny.
He killed dude.
He's really fucking good.
He's a funny guy,
man.
I don't know how long that guy has been doing.
Stand up.
I think they said four years.
Keep an eye on him.
Jeff sewing,
And one of the things I love about that place is it's open like a to like young
up and coming comics.
They can make a name for themselves.
They're like,
people,
like there's some people that on the show last night,
um,
that weren't that good.
And there's,
there's a couple that were like kind of shaky,
but the fact that they get a chance,
like if you're,
if you're,
you don't have to have a bunch of,
you know,
resume items that you can call upon.
You don't have to have like a bunch of,
uh,
credits to your name.
You could just be a local comic who is down on their luck.
You go up there and you can crush like this guy,
this Jeff Guy and just smash
it and then we'll be talking about you the next day and everybody will be
talking about,
yeah,
it's just an amazing showcase and it's alive fucking experience.
Like roast battle is one of the cool,
like it was never there when I was there in the old days of the comedy store.
This new Vr,
it's one of the pieces of um,
the new comedy store that like that I point to when I talk about how much better
it is there now,
it's just a better environment.
Everything's better that a young up and coming guys are better.
The young girls,
they're all better.
There's just more energy,
more life.
And then this shit like killed Tony and the roast battle.
Those two things are just giant for that place.
Giant.
It's great for new comics.
It's one of the best things ever.
Have both of those shows or shows to kill Tony's giant for new comics.
Giant.
And there's,
yeah,
and there's so many comics that are like a,
you know,
that are on kill Tony.
They have almost become regulars that are already surpassing people that have
been doing it for 10 years in me and Cami just because of the Internet and,
and the idea of it being broadcast and podcasts and stuff.
It's great for them.
It forces you to like hit another level early.
You know,
especially like girls like Kim and Sarah because they're doing,
if you never watched or listened to kill Tony on the death squad podcast
network,
it um,
killed Tony is a podcast where they have new comics go up.
They do one minute of you.
You've seen it,
right?
Yeah,
that's true.
Have you ever been on it?
No,
I'd never been on it should be on it as a host or as a judge rather.
It's awesome.
So fun seeing it happen.
Yeah.
And not really a judge.
They're like a comedy expert comic working comic.
So they do a minute,
everybody knows one minute and then the comics talk about your minute and
sometimes they go,
dude,
you're fucking awesome.
You got a real future.
And sometimes they go,
just stop.
Don't do this anymore for a day job.
Keep it actor.
But Kim and Sarah do a new minute.
Yeah.
Kim Cognitive.
Sarah wan Shank to a new minute every week.
Wow.
Gangster.
So ballsy to be able to do that.
To be able to come up with a new mat and to put it on the Internet.
So they're all of their comedy career like for,
especially Kim from the beginning to like,
Sarah did it a little while before she did ballsy.
Haulover sets all of our sets,
every brand new minute every week and it,
because of that it forces her and she,
she won last night in the roast battle.
Very close fucking battle.
Like he could have gone either way easily.
It was amazing.
She ended it.
Well,
she ended up with a bomb.
Yeah,
she did it.
She knows how to do it.
I mean she's,
this is her fifth win at roast battle.
She knows how to handle it.
She's a fighter.
That Dude Jeff though,
he was fucking vicious.
Oh.
Like I felt bad laughing at some of the shit that he was saying,
but it was poor girl.
It was ruthless.
So she tried,
she tried,
she went after him and she got him with some good ones too,
but he had some nuclear weapons.
It was fucked up.
It was like she pulled out some big cannons and fucked him up and then he just
dropped nuclear bombs and leveled the landscape to the point where people were
falling out of chairs.
I was curled up in the fetal position on the two chairs and then the Negro wave
the,
they have these guys,
if you never watched a roast battle before these got,
and you can watch it on periscope too.
You don't have to be in la.
But if you are in la on a Tuesday night,
get to the Goddamn comedy store and you got to get tickets early cause it's
always sold out.
But they have this,
whenever someone kills with a joke,
the Negro wave jumps up and they scream.
And that was a Jamal who the dude,
he poured water on himself.
Shamar Jomar Oh my God,
this kid's funny.
He's a real yoked black dude with a shaved head.
He pulls his pants down to like the middle of his Dick and he poured,
they pour water on him and he's dancing.
He climbs up on chairs and he's grinding in people's faces and it's all just
because this joke was,
it killed so hard that they act up and get crazy and it makes it 10 times
funnier.
Yeah.
It's such a good show.
Like every time I walk out of there I have this giant smile on my face and I
feel like I've seen something cool.
I feel like I've been a part of something like this is like,
I don't know,
there's no place like this.
I don't know any,
yeah,
I saw they did one in Montreal this week too.
Yeah,
yeah.
They're doing another Montreal too.
Yeah,
they did it at the festival.
So it's fucking great.
And you're doing a podcast with Brian Moses,
right?
It was as close to way we actually have the podcast version of,
uh,
the roast battle on desk squat now called verbal violence with coach t and Brian
Moses.
And it's the second episode was released in a third episode.
Should be anytime now.
Beautiful.
And Brian Moses water.
Good Dude.
We got to have him in.
Yeah.
He's such a dude.
Such a funny dude and just a good comic.
He's going to be great.
That kid is going to be giant verbal violence available violence.
Um,
so what else is going on?
Esther?
Why don't you have a podcast?
Do you have a podcast?
Well,
I do want to start a podcast and should I actually,
this one today,
I did record three episodes.
What happened to them?
Um,
I'm just waiting to get more before I released them.
What would you do that,
because like in case I don't find more people or you know what I mean?
Can you say run out?
What if I like air three episodes,
one each week or once every Monday,
and then the fourth week I just,
I don't have to do a solo on.
That's okay.
And moved to California and see the beautiful thing.
Yeah.
You can move to California and Brian,
I'll just sexually harass you every week,
but you can do one whenever you want.
That's the beautiful thing about the Internet,
right?
You don't have to be regular,
No,
no.
You have a bunch of of Twitter followers,
Facebook friends and all that jazz and wanting to start a podcast and I have a
name for it.
What's it called?
Cuckoo for cocoa puffs?
No,
it's called the Poo podcast because I like talking about my poop.
All right,
and you and Brian,
we should get married.
Well that's not gonna work out,
but maybe she just be friends.
Can put babies,
I think almost.
No.
What does she get married?
How about that?
Yeah.
Just nothing wrong with being together.
But here's the thing about the marriage that's really goofy is the legal
contract aspect of it to bring in other people and signing paperwork and stuff.
Just like,
but how can you like stamp that on,
you know,
it's
just,
so the only way it makes sense to me is when you have children,
you have children and the wife doesn't want to get stuck with no money.
I have a friend who's married,
who's not married and is pregnant,
and I know that baby is going to grow up in a loving home with two parents.
You know,
like you don't have to get married to have kids in that scenario.
I hope you correct,
but I think for a lot of women they want like legal protection.
They want to be able to like be able to get money out support,
not just child support,
but even alimony,
be able to pay for themselves too.
If they've been living their life,
being taken care of the child and made some sort of a mutual Deon and the dude
just decides a fucking jet.
Listen Bitch,
I moved to Jamaica,
wanted to get married.
It just seems like you're just tied down.
Well that's why they made divorce.
But you aren't tied down.
I mean that's exactly what it is.
It's a legal contract.
It's crazy.
The only thing that makes sense,
like I said,
the only time it makes sense if you have children,
this is coming from someone's happy.
He marries a green card.
That's a good move for it too.
I know people who've done that.
That's a good move.
I get that.
Make $15,000 but if you have children I can get,
I can understand why a woman would want some sort of a legally binding sort of
some sort of a insurance that she's going to be getting money from this guy that
she had babies with.
That makes sense to me.
You know what drives me crazy though is the non baby alimony.
My,
you don't have babies and you have to pay forever.
Like I have a buddy who was married for more than 12 years and if you know a
California works,
but California works,
if he,
if it goes over a certain amount of years,
I think it's like 12 you have to pay alimony forever,
forever,
forever.
Forever,
Until they die.
No,
and there's no kids.
There's no kids.
Here's my,
here's my friend's story at common law.
Married,
married,
common law.
Marriage I believe is a much different,
I think you could just sue the shit out of somebody if you have a common law
marriage,
like have you been living together and they've been supporting you for certain
amount of time.
But this is,
this is my friend's story and this is a very good friend.
So I know the details of this intimately.
I've had fucking sweaty conversations with this guy where if I introduced him to
a Hitman,
he probably would have taken it.
He probably would have not really,
he's not a murderer.
I don't want to get my friend in trouble.
But my friend was married to this woman for a long time and the last few years
it was real rough and he's just like,
God damn and I can't do this anymore.
And he doesn't know what to do.
And then,
uh,
one day decided to get out and she was furious and she prolonged the divorce
forever.
She tortured him during the divorce because when you don't have a Prenup,
then you have to argue over each point of the divorce.
Well,
her idea was since it was all his money,
because she didn't have a job and he was supporting her,
he had to pay for her lawyer as well as his lawyer.
I heard some lawyers do it for free knowing that they'll get paid at the end.
Oh,
most certainly they would do that,
but they don't have to do that.
If the woman is in a scenario where the man pays for everything and she doesn't
have a job,
well the man has to pay for her fucking divorce.
It's like going to war and you have to pay for the other armies general.
She doesn't have a job and has no income and has been living off of whatever he
makes.
How are they supposed to go to court if he doesn't pay for her lawyer?
Get a fucking job.
I mean,
she's done.
She doesn't have kids.
There's no reason why she doesn't have a job,
but he,
even though he doesn't want to be with her anymore,
he's legally bound to be with her.
Okay,
so he has this,
this law contract with her,
this legal marriage contract,
and it goes on for almost two years where she makes an agreement.
They,
they'd come to some sort of agreement and then she drags it out even further.
She changes the,
what she wants and she's allowed to do that.
She's allowed to change it,
whatever she would,
she doesn't have to agree to anything.
So she keeps fighting it as,
since she's fighting it with his money.
She's just bullying Yam and bleeding.
I mean,
she knows he has a lot of money.
She knows exactly how much money he makes,
so she keeps bleeding them over and over and over again.
She used to do his bookkeeping.
No,
she didn't do his bookkeeping.
She's doing a damn thing.
She walked a little dog around Pacific Palisades.
That's what she did.
She didn't do nothing.
Isn't that where Jeffrey Lash was a yes,
this woman's an alien.
Anyway,
anyway,
my point is this shit went on for like two years and cost him insane,
ungodly amounts of money.
Then after it's all over,
he lost his house.
So she lives in this beautiful house.
It's overlooking the ocean.
I mean,
it is fucking stunning.
It's amazing house.
And he has to pay her alimony for the rest of her life until she gets married.
If she gets married or cohabitating with a man.
Ah,
but that's where,
this is where it's crazy.
So now she has a boyfriend,
but the boyfriend lives with her.
Why would he live in his fucking shitty house when they can live with this
beautiful house overlooking the ocean?
So the boyfriend moves in and then they sent inspectors over to find out if the
boyfriend is living there.
She knows the inspectors are coming.
So he grabs all this stuff,
puts in a fucking u haul,
literally drives a mile away.
Parks the u haul,
waits for the inspectors to leave.
Turns back around,
reloads all his shit back into the house again,
because he,
if,
if this guy and her married the gravy train stops.
But if the guy and her are together,
she gets hundreds of thousands of dollars every year,
hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Like she's living up in,
they went lifestyle with a man that she just used to date.
She used to date him.
They haven't been together like romantically in more than a decade.
But this guy every week is writing fat checks,
fat fucking checks and sending them off in the mail.
Hundreds,
it's driving him mad.
That's what Trump should run on.
What?
Divorce.
Alimony.
But it doesn't always work that way.
It's like this guy just,
it was a combination of a ruthless woman who knows the system.
Good lawyers that can manipulate a guy who makes a lot of money.
You know,
there's a lot of,
a lot of stuff involved in it.
He should uh,
hire inspectors are private investigators.
Get the inspectors to come back,
have the video of them taking it.
Not good enough.
It's not good enough.
He,
he could,
he could leave a certain amount of personal items there.
The point,
the point is like he,
they're manipulating it.
Like all he has to do is keep an apartment and he'd get of the shittiest
apartment in Compton and then like,
no,
this is my place.
And like stay over her house 99% of the time.
Just go over his house,
take a shit and leave and force them to get married.
Nope.
All they can't get on your knees.
Bitch proposed right now.
Yeah.
And because it's,
if it's common law after a certain amount of years,
I wonder if the money stops then bell.
Either way.
This guy is just beyond fucked and it drives him crazy and he doesn't,
you know,
he doesn't even like this person.
Not only does he not like or he knows that she spent millions of dollars fight
of his money,
fighting him in this divorce settlement.
And then once it came in,
I was talking about a guy who did anything terrible.
He didn't kill anybody.
He didn't rob anybody.
He didn't.
But he's become a victim of legal system and this legal system has him obligated
to pay this woman until she stops breathing on planet earth.
She's Christ,
so fuck California.
So she's only like,
I think she's in her forties so for 12 years.
Yeah.
So if they,
if they live another 30 or 40 years,
this fucking guy has to pay,
or hundreds of thousands of dollars a year.
And I think it's almost a million.
I think it's not just hundreds of thousands.
I think it's many,
many hundreds of thousands.
And he's a wealthy man.
Don't get me wrong,
he's done very well,
but he works for a living.
And this is a guy who has his own business checks for a living.
He's not a,
he's not a thief.
I mean,
he's not like,
this is not,
his guy's not doing anything unscrupulous to make this money.
So this is all money that he earned because he runs his own business and he's a
fucking workhorse,
this guy.
And he dated a woman that was better looking than him.
He fucked up.
He dated.
A woman has better looking at him and it didn't work out.
And then,
you know,
he just thought,
I don't need a prenuptial.
I love her.
She hasn't won a prenuptial.
So this is how crazy this guy is.
He gets married again after this and his new wife wants to have no prenup.
And he was,
he was thinking of going through with it and everybody was fucking grabbing
this.
We've been going through this with you for the past three fucking years.
You are not going to do it.
No,
he didn't.
He got a Prenup,
got a very generous Prenup,
but as a prenup and they got married.
The point being a prenup at least if it,
even if it's ridiculous,
even if like you know Esther and Brian get married and and Brian is to pay
Esther a million dollars a year for the rest of her life.
If they break up,
at least that's set in stone where she can't say,
fuck you Brian,
I want $3 million.
I can't believe I sucked your Dick or can't believe that.
That's what happens when people get angry at each other when they get divorced.
They just fight and they fight and they fight and then there becomes this,
I'm going to break this motherfucker and then you figured out how to do it.
Getting married is a divorce.
Fights sound fucking awful.
Well the only sound awful because they can be awful.
That's the thing that's really crazy about marriage.
It just,
cause they can be awful.
You can demand,
there's a legal thing going on.
There's a contract that's disputed so you can battle about it.
Whereas like if you guys were just dating,
okay and you broke up.
Well that's it.
It's over.
I,
Brian says,
I don't want to date you anymore.
And you're like,
fuck you went on a date.
You anymore either,
but I want money.
Brian would be like,
what are you talking about?
I'm not giving you money.
Get away from me.
You know like get Outta here.
Stop.
Will you change your phone number?
And we're over.
It's over the,
the,
the battle ends.
But if you're married,
the battle is just be just be guys.
And then the lawyers get together and they,
they touch each other and they rub hands and they go,
we're going to clean this motherfucker out because you've got two lawyers who
are working for the same guy and they're battling a different position.
One boy,
he's working for you,
but you're battling for the wife,
but you're still getting the checks from the same guy.
He's fun.
So they know that they only have to do is stretch this dance out.
So they kept this dance going for I think more than two years.
More than two years.
This guy was going through divorce.
Wow.
Jess
and I would see me be gray,
like gray skin,
sweaty and fucking just freaking the fuck out.
Just hemorrhaging money,
hemorrhaging and working all day,
working everyday,
nine,
10 hours a day,
coming home.
Exhausted.
Yes.
You want to kids.
It's not just that he,
uh,
you know,
he loves this woman.
Just those other women.
The ladies just not,
it's not that he doesn't believe in relationships,
it's just the relationship that he had just didn't work.
And he was,
you know,
he just couldn't,
sometimes it doesn't work.
Sometimes people are great,
sometimes you're great and he's great to pay alimony to the guy because when
they started going out,
he was making more money and then she started surpassing him and wrote a
screenplay.
And then those moments are so rare.
I hate when people even talk about them.
That's like the when when women say sometimes women rape men.
Okay,
maybe they do it a million times that the women are paying alimony.
How rare are those
50 Joe?
Well then with,
it would be a good argument to quit alimony.
Let's just bail on it.
You know,
I think alimony is nonsense.
I think if you do have someone know that you've been taken care of for a certain
amount of time,
like if you care about them at all,
you have an obligation to help them.
You know what?
I don't like people struggling financially.
I think it's a horrible thing to see.
That's one of the most stressful things in your life.
And if someone can help someone and was sort of like help them move along till
like a more prosperous future without them.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But when you get obligations like my friend who's like,
I think he has to be seven or $800,000 a year,
she is forever.
Forever.
What if he start lakes?
What if he doesn't make as much money next year?
And you know what,
I think I might be wrong.
I think it's more than a million now that I'm thinking about it because there's
a bunch of other,
there's like a bunch of shit tacked in.
There's all this,
oh,
it's so crazy.
And this is like what he settled on.
This is what he settled for 400 over 400,000 people in the United States
receiving post divorce,
spousal maintenance,
just percent were men.
And how many of those were from the gay dudes?
How many of those?
Cause Miss Melissa Etheridge plays alimony.
Two or two ex wives.
It's funny gracing.
Anybody ever said on this podcast,
I asked her,
I go,
how do you,
can I go?
How are you paying alimony to two ex wives go,
she goes,
bitches are crazy.
She might have,
she might be one of them fucking Turkey based or ladies put the strap on a
Turkey based turns like shit.
Yeah,
she was it her that had like David Crosby's come and pregnant in one of her
girlfriends or something like that.
People get freaky,
you know,
they do little things.
Try to do a little test things.
This gay couple of live down the street from me and the guy is,
there's one guy that works all the time and the other guys like sorta the house
husband,
they have a great,
great relationship with a housewife.
You know,
they have a kid and uh,
the,
the guy that doesn't work does most of the taking care of the kid and his
beautiful,
it works for them.
They're there sweeties they're the nicest folks.
They're like their,
you know,
their kid comes over parties and stuff and they're like,
their kid is the same age as my kids.
We played together all the time.
He's always over the house to the nicest people.
Just for someone who doesn't know gay people,
it just seems weird that these two guys are in love with each other and that
they hold hands and,
but once you get used to them,
the dynamic of them,
you know who they are,
they're the nicest,
friendliest people and they get along.
It works great.
Like they'd been together for years
and the kids,
not traumatized kids fine.
The kids like this is awesome.
My Dad's are awesome.
One of the reasons why the kids finds,
because we live in California and California is very open minded when it comes
to gay people,
it's more open minded I think in any place else I've ever lived.
It's like uh,
you know,
so much so that it's,
it's becoming more of an issue if you're a homophobe than it is if you're gay.
Like if people find out you're homophobic,
it's so repulsive.
It's like,
what do you give a shit?
I that's more repulsive than it is.
Like if you're a homophobic person,
you see a gay person like this,
it's almost more,
more stigmatizing to be homophobic than it is.
Like as far as like numbers go than it is to be gay almost.
That would be the goal,
right?
The goal would be to make being a homophobe horrible.
He's just amazing as far as just people.
People don't want to offend you that they go so far as to like be like,
oh,
what'd you like to,
you know,
get a breast implant?
Who,
man,
you know what I mean?
Like it's just trans like gender.
People are just everywhere.
And it's,
it's so,
except there's a transgender comedian in San Francisco.
Have you seen him?
Her,
sorry,
miss gendered chemists.
Gender.
It's super bad.
I forget her name,
but she was hilarious.
I don't understand people getting upset at something is obviously a mistake as
miss gender.
Like if you used to be a man and now you're a woman and someone actually calls
you relax.
Okay,
relax.
Cause if you call me a she,
guess what I'm not getting upset at.
Yeah,
I'm just not if you like,
have you seen Joe Rogan?
Oh my God,
she's really funny.
Hmm.
On the regular wouldn't bug me,
you know,
like whatever.
So people call you a he,
I mean just like you make a mistake.
Like it's almost like,
like ma'am,
like when you got to go,
thanks ma'am.
Sure.
Right.
That's a dude.
What it is.
It's a mystery.
Call your your friend.
That's a girl brother.
All right brother.
I'll see you soon.
We'll miss that.
But oh dude.
Or Bro,
but to,
to dude's okay dude is fruit called universal dude.
You're like guys like,
hey guys.
Like there could be like four girls and a guy and he's like,
what's up guys?
And nobody gets upset and if they do stop hanging out with them.
Right.
Because if someone says guys is not really just got the problem is it's so
gender specific,
there's no like female
equivalent to guys,
you know,
where you could say a bunch of girls can be guys,
but that just sounds dumb.
Do you have a,
nobody's scared.
You know what I'm saying?
No,
no,
no one uses it universally.
Like you don't see a group of men and someone says,
hey girls or hey gals,
but you could see like five girls and go,
what's up guys?
What's up?
And somehow or another,
it's acceptable.
Girls like you can go up to your friends and go,
what the fuck you guys doing?
You can actually say that,
right?
That's right.
It's not weird.
It's like it happens all the time.
Yeah.
What is that?
How is that?
Because we just live in such a male dominated world.
Is that frustrating being a woman?
Um,
well it was when I was a kid.
Yeah.
Because like I just was surrounded by guys so I thought,
you know,
so I felt like I have three brothers so I was just like constantly battling for
the toilet
is that way.
So I'm talking about poop.
Well No,
you know what it is.
It's like I grew up seeing my brother's like pee in the toilet together cause
they could stand next to each other and all p at the same time that I just got
so jealous.
I was like,
when I pee,
I take up the whole toilet by myself.
I can't hang out with people while peeing.
And I thought,
man,
it would be awesome.
You're going to see those things.
Have you seen those things as they have for Women Where They Get pee outdoors?
It's like a funnel you put over your box.
They have that at like bass pro shops and stuff.
I've seen it.
Yeah,
I'd you can go.
I want to try it.
It has good reviews online.
Yeah.
Well the kind of people that I just thing I just enjoy
over a pile of leaves.
Do you know?
Yeah.
If you're camping,
do you camp?
I've gone camping.
How many times?
Twice.
Did you enjoy it?
It was so much fun.
Where'd you go?
I went in,
um,
Florida is silver's silver lake,
silver springs.
See Camping in Florida.
It takes on a totally different meaning because you could easily run into a meth
heads are crazy people out there in the woods.
Yeah.
Alligators,
snakes.
You're lucky you only went twice.
I know.
Well maybe the third time I will.
That's like going hunting for Ufo is twice and saying that it was nothing out
there.
You never know.
There's a lot of,
yeah,
I was surprised at like everybody just left all their stuff in the open when
they ride,
ride their bikes down the path,
you know,
go down to the beach and everybody just has their stuff and you're just on the
honor system.
Yeah.
You know,
and like nothing gets stolen and it's not like it happens right all the time.
That's our big problem with camp grounds.
Shiny problem shorts.
Like lock your shit up.
Well,
I mean if you have anything really valuable,
you lock it up in your car.
But yeah,
people's tents get robbed all the time.
Oh Damn.
Well,
it's just one of those things.
And it also attracts a lot of vagrants and a lot of people that are,
you know,
they're down on their luck.
And that's where the sleeping in a tent.
There's people that are essentially homeless,
but they have a tent,
you know?
And if you have a cut public campground and there's a shower there,
you can kind of get a reservation at a public campground that's like hard to get
to.
Like you take a ferry and then you get a guy in a jeep picks you up and you know
you're in trolley and it takes you down to your camp site.
Brian ever tell you about being from Kevin and bean.
He lives on an island.
He lives on an island outside of Seattle.
Mm.
You can't even get to it unless you take a ferry guy lives on an island out in
the middle of the fucking the bay.
And you know,
he's kind of in Seattle,
but he does.
He ever,
did.
You ever know Kevin and being the best?
They're,
they're awesome.
And they're still around.
They're like one of the last radio shows is still around,
but he um,
he is wired into the La Studio so he lives in Seattle and Kevin still lives in
La and the gas come to la when I go,
when I do the show,
I do it in studio and um,
except when I call in tomorrow I'm calling in,
but when I do it in studio,
you sit down there with Kevin and being is over the loudspeaker and it sounds
like he's right there with you,
but you don't see him.
He's like the eye in the sky.
He's like,
God,
you think they would have it like at least a Skype system going on so you could
at least see him?
No,
you don't see him see him bed?
He's,
well he,
you can see them.
They have some sort of a setup where you could see him on a video camera or
something like where that Talia delay?
No,
no delay.
because it's like an ISD n line.
So the delay is so minuscule knows,
can't tell.
No,
you can't tell.
Yeah.
W The delay is like difference between this and this.
Like it's so short,
it's like this,
this,
it's like the,
it's like maybe a half second.
Not even,
you know,
it's like an internet lag.
So yeah,
it's like paying,
yeah.
So if you're saying something and you know the,
the amount of,
it's not like that critical that what you're saying has to be like an eighth of
a second Corker.
Just whenever it comes out,
it seems like it's real time so that he,
he does it from an island,
but I always wanted like,
I don't know if I could do that,
man.
I don't know if I could live on an island.
I would kind of weird me out.
Yeah.
There's this place in San Diego that's like,
that I went to where you take a ferry over and then it's just like this small
island and it's a whole community though.
They have like a little grocery store,
a little Sushi place,
dry cleaner,
but just houses everywhere.
Uh,
but it's completely cut off.
If there's a bad storm or something like that.
They can't have the ferry.
Everyone's stuck or not stuck on that island.
There's that island outside of a San Diego that all the super rich people live.
That's the island,
I think.
Yeah.
That's like Dick Cheney.
He's got a house out there and yeah.
Yeah.
That's a spooky spot.
Have you been,
so you've been to that?
It's so,
I've never been,
oh,
it's so weird.
We went there and ate,
what's it called?
I think it's core natto out.
Yes.
That's exactly what it's called.
Yeah.
There was,
um,
some sort of a murder mystery that was going on there.
There was some unsolved murder in some really wealthy family that they felt like
some shenanigans are taking place.
I can't remember the store.
And you know the story.
Do you know about it?
You know how it goes?
The wife was Margaret.
Yeah.
There's some shenanigans with the son.
The son got murdered.
I don't remember.
No,
he's the worst though.
Murder
on Coronado island.
Say murder.
Mystery.
Murder.
Uh,
death of Rebecca is how the cranked up here.
It was discovered dead July 13th,
2011.
She was like the step mom and they thought that she killed his son.
And so all of a sudden she goes missing and she's murdered.
Oh,
this is what happened.
She died two days after this guy's son,
Max took a fatal fall from a staircase,
banister in the same beach house.
The woman was the only adult present at the time of his fall.
So she killed his son or she fucked up.
Um,
Bill Gore announced September 2nd,
2011.
That's a how,
whose death was a suicide while the younger or something,
something was an accident and that neither was the result of foul play.
Remember as a host family sued,
uh,
Max's parents for $10 million disputing the contention that her death was
suicide.
Huh?
How'd that settle?
How'd the lawsuit play out?
So you can sue someone for something like civil lawsuits are really tricky.
It's like where,
uh,
oh,
Jay's like got sued because of,
uh,
the dude's family.
What was his name?
You know,
there's a,
his wife and then the boyfriend Ron gold.
Ron Goldman.
Yeah.
Ron Goldman's family sued and won.
And that's why he had to like go bankrupt his Heisman trophy or something.
Yeah,
they got his Heisman.
But who wants that?
You know,
try selling that fucking gross.
This woman,
no,
I don't think they know.
No one was there except the dude and her and he probably pushed her off the
fucking side.
But I was like pitching show my baby most likely.
It seems like it.
She might've killed herself too.
She might have fucking hated him,
blaming her for a stupid kid jumping.
So He's,
she's like,
you know what pitch?
I'm gonna get you in trouble.
I'm thinking to myself,
it was a huge house,
so he,
the boy like could've just fallen off a staircase and just died accidentally.
She's probably wasn't paying attention.
That's probably why.
If someone wanted to kill her,
that's why they would want to kill her.
Just they were furious that you weren't paying attention.
You got to watch two year olds,
like you gotta be right there with them all the time.
He was six,
he was six it said.
Is that what it says?
What do I think?
It's two,
six.
Yeah.
He,
you know,
even six year olds,
they,
they actually,
sometimes you have to watch them even more because they get real cocky.
Six year olds in a big mansion with a banister staircase.
Well,
if you do,
you have to fucking pay attention to them.
I mean,
who knows?
But who knows what happened.
You know,
we don't know what happened with the kid.
We don't know what happened to her.
There might've been some weird shit with him or her.
Okay.
What does it say in July 13 2011 a nude body of Xy who was found bound and hang
from a balcony at the famous speckled mansion Coronado.
A cryptic message written in black paint was found just outside the second story
room in the house.
Which red?
She saved him.
Can you save her?
What?
I'm confused.
She can wait a minute.
I thought she fell.
Okay.
Amended Lawsuit.
Rebecca is a how beaten,
strangled and pushed off a balcony.
She was found dead so that,
oh,
okay.
This is a totally different story.
This was from last year.
Oh,
so now there,
so it's still going on.
Whoa.
Scroll down here.
$10 million claiming,
um,
lawsuits claiming Rebecca,
how was this is what homes blowing?
I'm saying it weird.
Z A h.
A U I think you spelled that.
I think you pronounce that.
So how so how's death was a murder and not a suicide?
It's been amended to allege new details.
About three people conspired to kill her being gay and strangling her with the
autopsy.
She,
it couldn't have been a suicide.
Really.
They found marks on her body.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
well who knows,
who knows?
She might have been evil.
She might've killed the kid.
They might have killed her accident.
I don't know.
But I mean if they found her hanging,
if they really did find her hanging,
like it says there,
the document goes on to claim that the trios trucks out on the head multiple
times,
the blunt instrument physically restrained,
her gagged her,
bound her and strangled her to the point of unconsciousness or death.
Huh?
I Dunno,
I don't even want to know.
It's creepy from a lawsuit that this is all coming from to not like an official
police ruling.
Right.
So this is just their claims.
Is that what it is?
I think that's what this project,
I know what opened again,
probably some people that at one point in time are madly in love.
They loved each other,
asked her,
they wanted to be together forever and ever and ever.
I love you.
I hug you.
How do you know who's who's going to kill?
You know what I mean?
Like these people,
they,
they weren't,
they didn't pick up on the red flags.
If there were any,
well,
there might be no indication up until the point where that kid died.
I mean,
the kid dying might've been like this fucking dumb bitch.
You know,
I might've been like the straw that broke the camel's back.
I mean,
the,
if they did murder her,
that might be what or who knows?
She might be evil.
I mean,
she might've been just a horrible person and they might have hated her already.
And then when she killed the kid,
she might have pushed the kid.
Who knows?
People are assholes.
There's a lot of creepy fucks out there in this world.
Maybe she kills him that true kind of like,
you know,
you,
you would think that she didn't,
I would like to think it was an accident.
Yeah.
I would like to think that both of them were an accident.
You,
the civil suit is just frivolous,
but you never know.
Of course.
You never know.
You were talking about,
you know,
taking care of a two year old and Jamie,
I just emailed you a video.
There's this video that somebody posted last night and it's one of the most we
saw already,
I,
and Josh it onto here.
I don't want to know if we should show it on here.
What the escalator,
no,
no.
I just emailed you,
uh,
somebody,
somebody put a posted this last night and it's one of these videos I had
something to do about a kid in a little kid in a swimming pool and this little
kid falls in the swimming pool,
but it has been trained,
uh,
to,
survive.
And this kid is like a baby can't even talk.
And so it's,
it shows this little baby.
And at first you're like,
what the fuck is going on?
This baby falls in the pool and then the baby just learned how to float and just
sitting there going and it is the creepiest coolest video.
Oh,
babies are really fat.
They can float pretty good.
Yeah.
Awesome.
It didn't pan out.
Yeah.
But when you see this video,
it's one of the most interesting videos to watch because it's,
it's something you don't want to see mixed with the baby knowing what it's
doing.
So it has this really uneasy feel to it.
Here's the baby walking out and has great sound on it also.
If,
um,
but it's uh,
so they did this on purpose.
They made this video on purpose just to show that the baby can do,
yeah,
I can show this baby.
He's a baby now.
This is not even a two year old watch.
This is a little tiny toddler.
And who's recording this?
There's the,
the dads are recording this and watch,
this is where the baby falls in.
Okay.
Like this baby's done this
before the baby,
right?
Right.
Jumped in the water
kicks.
Wow.
Amazing flopping around.
And then it's up to the surface and then watch.
Just relaxing.
I know.
It's beautiful.
Oh,
wait a minute.
Is this a suit he's wearing is a special suit?
No,
I think this is just this little pajamas.
Are you sure?
But I don't,
you know,
I have no idea.
Wow.
Let me start.
It starts actually talking.
It's Kinda fucked it.
They leave them there like this for this long.
I get the video,
dude.
Go of your fucking kid.
And guess what?
This goes on for another minute.
Cut it off.
If you cut to the very end,
you could see where the bay,
look how it's really cute baby.
When the guy grabs it at the very end of the video.
Uh,
let's see.
And it's just happy as can be.
He's laughing.
I said that was interesting and creepy,
but it is interesting.
I wonder if it's a suit or if it's a,
they just taught the kid the line is back and they just naturally float.
I think a lot of is probably they panic,
you know,
they don't even need a bathing suit.
It was like awesome.
Yeah.
Babies and pools are vert very fucking dangerous.
That's one of the most dangerous things when you have children as worrying about
them falling into a pool.
One of a Dhimmi Moore's kids,
a kid drowned at her party the other day.
Apparently Dimmy more has,
you know Bruce Willis is kids and they are rangers.
When dummies out of town,
they just have fucking rage or is every night
and somebody will end up dead.
Appboy wound up dead face down in the pool.
I believe he was 21 nope.
Some boy,
some did.
Ran Out of calm high on meth.
Fell into the pool.
Fucking dead.
I'm sorry if it was your son.
I don't mean just,
you know,
little things man,
how insensitive they become a non did become a note and they don't become a real
person,
you know?
Oh God.
Yeah,
totally.
That's a scary shit thing,
man.
Leave your kids alone at home and one of their friends dies and you're fucking
pool like,
oh Christ alcohol and Waterman.
Super,
super dangerous.
Yeah.
I mean look at that girl who passed out in the highway that we watched that one
time.
The video.
Now imagine somebody just like hanging out,
like,
you know,
drinking beer and just slips and falls asleep.
And next thing you know,
you know,
whenever I think about alcohol and pools,
you know what to think about those images from the Bryan singer,
gay parties that he used to have with the red pool water and the 50,000 dudes in
their underwear in the pool.
That's,
I,
I am stuck thinking about that forever.
Whenever I think about the fact that,
you know,
like whenever someone says like Pool Party,
people drunk at the pool.
I think of that image cause it was,
have you ever seen it?
It's the craziest shit ever.
Bryan singer who uh,
the guy who will look at that.
He's the guy who directed,
no,
that's just lights his red lights in the water.
The guy who directed the x men,
he's a gay dude,
likes to party.
And so he has these parties with all these,
uh,
young studs and twinks and they just fill a pool.
Not from rip to,
yeah.
You already talked about when you couldn't wait.
Could you
look at that?
That everybody drink beet juice,
gay suit.
But that's what I think about.
I think about pools
and alcohol.
I think this the out of control scenario.
Yeah.
Nah,
Nah.
That's what was going on to Jimmy Moore's house.
The Lyft driver last night.
Joe Saw you 20 years ago and you said something to an audience member that he
says that he says to himself every single day since you've seen you,
what does loan,
it's because you were,
there was some woman heckler and you said,
where did you learn to whisper a sawmill?
That's a hack line.
That's a Hagwon
he says he uses that,
all of this is he the,
he he thinks about it every day.
I need he and uh,
yeah,
people that's,
that's a hack line.
That's a like a standard,
like a stock line.
Where'd you learn to lose per helicopter?
That's another one.
What'd you weren't doing this for?
A,
you know a warzone?
Yeah,
it's hack at it.
Write it down.
Cause he just also,
there was a guy named Brent that worked at the comedy store and he said that him
and uh,
this guy named Brent and I lives in Vegas and a dom Barris all went to a strip
club once.
He says it was the most insane I'd ever,
cause don was,
Don was just screaming at all this.
I can see Ferris doing his ass
to this.
Trippers yeah,
Don Barris is never,
that's another thing about the comedy store that's amazing is the late night
sets by Brodie,
Brian Holtzman and dawn Barris.
Those are staples,
the staples.
Dot.
Barry's got mad at me one night for what?
I forgot what happened.
He brought me on stage on his late show.
Dong or Ding Dong show or was it a regular show?
It was just a regular show.
He was just the last one.
Okay.
And he brought you on stage?
He brought me on stage.
Cause you were after the show,
is that what it was?
No,
no,
no.
I was just hanging out and there were like four people there.
Right.
You know what I mean?
And he brought me on stage and was like,
what do you do?
I was like,
I'm a comedian.
You know?
Like that's what I had.
That's how I met Don Barris is he brought me on stage.
And how did he get mad at you?
I don't remember what happened,
but
I dunno.
People were like,
people who are like scared for me.
People were scared for you?
Well,
I guarantee you who's playing.
Yeah,
he was doing Don Baer.
He does dom Barris.
Right?
That's fine.
That's what he does.
Yeah.
He starts screaming.
He's not mad at all.
I know.
And I said,
no,
he's just kidding.
Yeah.
You know?
And they're like,
no,
that was too crazy.
Who are the people that said it was too crazy?
I don't remember.
It was stop hanging out with them.
It was like five years ago.
Yeah.
You need new friends.
They're idiots.
Done.
But he's,
he might've been audience members.
You know,
they always fall for it.
Well,
that if you don't know,
like people used to think that Brody was serious.
Like people who've never met Brody before.
Like,
I have a bunch of friends that saw Brody for the first time and went like,
oh my God,
this guy's terrible.
And then they see him five times and they go,
oh,
he's amazing.
I get,
he's my favorite comedian now learning
curve.
That's exactly when I first met him was that the man show when I went to go see
man show a w uh,
with you and I was in the audience for like two episodes with horse flesh and he
would scream at the audience,
you know,
he was the audience,
warm up guy.
But if you didn't know who
he was,
and at the time I was just like,
this guy's making this clap.
He's yelling at us.
We thought like,
I thought he was Hitler like that.
I mean,
and I remember coming up to him when I eventually met him later at the comedy
store with you.
I remember going,
Jesus Christ,
man,
I was,
I hated you.
I think that's nice when people come up to you and say,
You'd like that.
Okay.
Yeah,
because then that means you like them now,
right?
You've won them over.
No.
Yeah,
but it's cool when people can admit that.
Do people say that to you?
Yeah.
Did you,
is it guys usually know it can be guys.
Yeah.
Guys will say shit like the girls just to knock him down a peg.
I actually hated you.
I don't even think you were hot right when it first.
Yeah.
Met You.
I hated you.
Or like,
or because I picked on somebody because they picked on somebody in the audience.
That's why they hated you.
They'll hate me.
No.
Yeah,
but why would you pick on Sunday?
You,
you,
if you were picking on someone,
I couldn't imagine being vicious.
You're not a vicious person.
So you think are very vicious.
Are you?
I can be vicious on stage into the microphone.
Yeah.
Why?
I'm just going to throw a punch because it's doggy dog.
Cause you gotta do what you gotta do.
Is that what it is?
No,
because like,
you know,
it's just easy to make fun of guys who are alone in a comedy club when everybody
else is in a couple in,
in a relationship.
How ironic that you make fun of those guys,
those the ones that would rape you and kill you.
It's weird.
No,
I'm your enemy.
I make fun of,
I made fun of the husbands and the boyfriends too.
Ah.
It's like sometimes the ones who are by themselves,
we'll get creepy.
Mad At me.
I'm sure.
Kiana.
Yeah,
dudes are creepy.
They're dangerous.
Yeah.
Picking on dudes is dangerous.
Well,
picking on like happily married or boyfriend dudes,
you know it's safer.
Safer.
I'm going to write this down.
Write it down.
He lesson 101 loners.
They don't pick on the loaner single dude,
the quiet loner at the colony club with his hands inside of his
would those big jackets from the outlaw Josey Wales?
Well those who's called trench coach edge cuts.
Have you,
have you made any music videos lately?
She has so many for hilarious music videos.
She's a very talented musician and when like one of her favorites,
my favorite songs that she does his card,
I bought a dildo on Amazon and stuff like that and she has these will really
close with the axis.
We've got to get out of here.
High quality videos?
No,
I'm in the process of,
I mean I'm,
I'm making videos right now so I'm recording songs and it's so good.
A new one will come out soon,
but
so can we play that?
I bought a deldot on Amazon,
on Amazon,
so great.
I prefer okay.
All right then what do you prefer?
I like,
um,
can you feel my menstrual pain?
Okay,
let's play that one.
Can we feel,
can you feel that menstrual pain,
Esther?
Cool.
Thank you very much for being here.
You guys can,
you guys can,
uh,
contact her on Twitter and harass her and Twitter allows you to send pictures of
your Dick so,
so far,
feel free.
Thank you for now.
They were about to change that you want,
I've never thought a dick pic on Twitter.
Pair yourself for a tsunami of veiny man meat cause it's on your way.
Guaranteed.
You have a picture of their,
but they're about what?
You're going to get that too,
but it's more than penises.
Your end of buttholes or buts like
penis,
penis fan.
Well I am,
but not looking at,
you know,
so you just like,
you don't like the Butthole,
you like the,
but it talks like a nice no ingrown hairs.
Something big.
Something that delivers the Bacon.
Right Esther?
Cool.
You could see her if you want to watch repeats of Girl Code,
but they didn't pay her so she kept moving.
Can you see,
can you feel my menstrual pain?
You could listen to this and watch this on youtube and you can catch Esther all
around the fucking world doing standup because she's gangster like that,
right?
You have a website,
[inaudible] dot com hard rock cafe,
hard rock in Atlanta.
All that linked up directly to your Twitter page.
So if you go to Twitter page,
your actual,
all your shit,
your stats and everything in there,
right?
Isn't it?
Yes.
Yes it is.
I remember it.
All right,
Brian Red band.
Did you have a Gig soon?
Tomorrow?
San Jose with a Dean del Rey Christian Spicer at the San Jose and Prague and
then my birthday show August 5th me,
you and a bunch of,
uh,
August 5th we'll,
we will be celebrating Brian red bands birthday.
I am going to get a fucking limousine because I ain't drive and we're getting
fucked up dude.
I'm getting you were going to get you ham her nice.
We're going down hard.
Brought Brian.
Sweetie is turning 48 years old.
That's what I am.
I'm old.
I'll be 48 in August.
I'm almost 40 now.
Remember when you turn 40 what else?
Shocking time waits for no man.
Damn.
I'm going to be 48 40 dark.
No Dude.
48 I was born in 1967 I was born August 11th,
1967 so this August 11th,
I'll be 48 years old.
Homeless Dude,
I'm closing on 50 yeah,
dude con Tom Cruise's 50 fucking one.
That's ridiculous.
It's crazy.
It's just,
it's happening.
Thank you very much.
I feel so good now.
Do some good.
I don't get depressed about my age.
It's like I get depressive body parts aren't working correctly,
you know,
like injuries and stuff like that.
But that's just for me being a retard.
It takes longer to heal,
to recover from an injury.
I fix all that other,
I go to doctors get the injections,
steroid injections don't really fix things.
Uh,
steroids can fixing cortisone mostly.
Yeah,
that's a little bit different
that that would really does with a cortisone shot does,
is really just numbs the pain.
It actually can become more problematic for people that have injuries because
you get a cortisone shot in your knee or in a,
you know,
your joints or something like that.
And then while you're working out,
you're not feeling any pain.
We were still doing injury.
You're still grinding on an injury and you can actually like Bas Rutten,
he's all fucked up cause he got cortisone shots in his knees and cortisone shots
in his elbows and he kept fighting,
you know,
like he had all this pain and so we just get cortisone shots and now it's just
joints are destroyed and he just like was too tough for,
for his own body.
But I got a stem cell injection.
I got one recently had,
I was worried that I was going to have to get shoulder surgery from a woman's
placenta.
Oh my God.
Total.
You mean next level?
Shit.
There's a company that collects women's stem cells from their menstrual blood
and stores planned parenthood's cause supposedly cells,
they aborted stem cells and makes money off of that.
But that might be abortion talk.
No,
I'm pretty sure that's not,
it seems like it should be bullshit,
but I'm pretty sure there's like a real investigation into that.
Yeah,
look,
it could,
it could happen because look,
the d the cells are viable and the idea of not using them to me is more fucked
up than using them.
I mean,
if you're going to end board a fetus,
shouldn't you at least use those cells?
Cycle it use every part.
But people were worried that people going to have abortions on purpose to make
money for the stem cells.
But anyway,
what they do is when a woman has a csection,
they take the placenta from the c section and they use it to,
uh,
they,
they harvest the stem cells from this,
they freeze it and then they thought out and injected into your injury.
And I had a shoulder that was fucking with me for like a year,
like a solid year.
I'd work out,
it would get swollen.
I said it would get better,
but it never totally got better and I could do most things,
but it was always in pain.
I got the stem cell injection two and a half weeks ago cause I was worried that
I was going to have to get surgery.
I had one doctor had said,
get surgery.
He's like,
you're probably gonna need surgery.
And then another doctor said,
I'm went to an actual orthopedic surgeon.
He was like,
no,
you have too much function,
moves it too much.
Let's just try to rehab it and see like if those tears,
if they'll,
they'll heal up.
I got the stem cell shot within two and a half weeks.
It feels like there's nothing wrong with my shoulder.
It's fucking crazy.
It's crazy because it's supposed to last like it's supposed to be like six to
eight weeks to when you say you feel the real impact.
And then I talked to Daniel Cormier,
Daniel Cormier,
the UFC light heavyweight champ.
He had a knee injury and his knee was fucked up and he was thinking about
getting surgery and he was putting it off.
And I talked to him a year ago about this.
He's like,
I don't know.
You know,
eventually when we get surgery I think,
and I'm trying to put it off,
he got the stem cells,
Bam.
All of a sudden he's like,
it's amazing.
It's like right away it felt better.
They feel,
and I don't know who it was,
but did I give her a hug?
Tell her they don't tell you.
Oh No,
no,
they definitely don't tell you because that woman's stem cells probably went to
untold numbers of people cause it's a small amount of the amount that they had
in this little,
in this little syringe,
when they inject it in,
you kind of connected to her in some way.
It's somewhere starting
your period and your neck.
Well,
I have some other stuff.
I have a cadaver,
a joint.
I have,
um,
my left knee has a cadaver.
No,
my right knee.
My right knee has a cadaver ACL.
It's extra a cadavers,
um,
uh,
Achilles tendon cause Achilles tendon as much fatter than a human ACL.
And so they take this kid Achilles tendon,
they open you up,
they put it in place,
screw it,
screw it down.
And then your body repopulates this cadaver the dead person's Achilles tendon.
So it's much thicker than a regular ACL.
So my ACL and my right knee is like 150% stronger than a regular ACL because it
was an a,
an ACL from an Achilles tendon.
Do you have two new inner voices that are new,
new inner voice?
I think that might be my problem.
Too much dead people,
parts and baby farms.
You have a girl's voice in a guy's voice,
but I'll tell you that growing baby teeth on your shoulder and we'll pull them
out.
The fucking pair of pliers.
And I'm a man.
I'm no,
it looks as long as it fixes my shoulder.
And right now if my shoulder does not get any better and stays right here and
doesn't get any worse,
I'm fucking super happy because there's no pain right now.
I mean I'm,
I'm not,
I'm not feeling any pain and I'm still doing all these rehab exercises so it's
all strong.
I can do things with it.
I might be able to avoid surgery.
I think there's just some tears in there,
but I'm pretty sure they're healing up.
Psalms going on in there.
It's great.
Some new next level shit happening.
But those lenses that can make you see way better than 2020 stem cell injections
when you have injuries.
I've never had anything.
He'll up this quick cause it's crazy.
It's kind of spooky because this thing was fucking with me for a long time,
man.
You know what?
When women have their periods,
we lose all our stem cells from the uterus lining.
They should collect it and store it and use it for when you need a stem cell for
your neck.
I think they're doing it.
I think they're doing that.
This company went bankrupt.
We're not bankrupt,
but they said enough people didn't get it.
So they're not collecting menstrual blood anymore,
but you know they do them from your own fat.
So here's a win.
When they take the fat out of your love handles,
they light Bo you and they take your faith.
You don't need any lipid hooker.
We talk.
I,
I do.
What do they do or is it just an even trade?
Like I wouldn't pay for it.
They don't,
they don't pay you for your fat.
Why don't take that much either.
Dude.
I have a lot though.
Yeah,
but they don't take enough.
Like you got to eat vegetables and go running up hills and stopped smoking
cigarettes.
So you get to stop what you're doing.
I can't believe you're back smoking cigarettes again.
Back to smoking a cigarette.
He smoked three cigarettes a day,
right?
Three cigarettes compared to two packs.
It's still smoking cigarettes.
Kinda Stop Dude.
I swear to God.
You know,
I talked to that writer that was in here.
It says one of my biggest fears,
I worry about you getting sick.
I really do cause you're always smoking.
You were at least for a long time.
I worry about it.
I that's a real,
that's one that gets you and once it gets he like,
fuck,
I could have avoided this.
That's a scary,
it's so scary to be close to someone and care about them like I care about you
and then see you smoking and know that that's eventually going to get you like,
do you
know that?
I think they need to make no smoking at the comedy store.
That's not going to ever happen.
That's never going to happen.
We just need to go to a vapor cigarettes.
Just go to vapor cigarettes and just,
and just tell yourself,
you can't smoke cigarettes.
I need to get new vapor.
You got free for a while.
How long did your free for?
A couple of months and I go,
yeah,
month,
month and a half.
Something like that.
You can do it,
dude do.
You can do it.
Oh,
I know a good deal.
Yeah.
You just have to want to do it.
I was trying to say,
when you're going to stop smoking cigarettes,
give yourself a couple of weeks.
You just start smoking,
right?
Not Cigarettes.
Weed.
You smoke weed Esther.
Yeah.
Waiting man.
Wait a minute.
You smoke pot.
That's how she makes this great music.
We smoke pot with her right before the show.
Brian,
do you think I forgot the dairy.
All right Esther,
thank you so much for being on a show.
It was a lot of fun.
It was always cool hanging with you at the store.
So I'm glad we finally got a chance to do this.
You're cool.
Chick strs for having me.
Cool human being.
I shouldn't qualify that.
You're a woman.
You're just,
you're just cool.
Cool Gal.
We Love Ya.
And uh,
Brian again,
tomorrow night he will be at the San Jose Improv,
which is one of the coolest clubs in the country.
It's a fantastic cloud.
Used to be an old theater,
really sweet,
sweet setup and that spot.
What?
The Great Dean del Rey.
And if you're a Harley Davidson fan as an extra bonus,
there'll be Harley Davidson's onstage.
Yeah.
Slow.
Are you dean sponsored by Harley.
So he brings the motorcycles.
They do.
They just shut the Harleys on stage with them.
He gets a free Harley.
He rides his own Harley that they gave him.
And then at the end of the year because he worked for Harley.
Yeah.
And you know there's their sponsors sponsored by pens.
You could totally get sponsored by pens,
but you get something probably better.
Yeah,
like tampons or some shit.
She go for that.
What's like your favorite thing in the world?
Um,
she's sponsored by Dick.
I'm just saying like what's your favorite thing that you get sponsored by?
Um,
how about some kind of food?
I love donuts.
Donuts.
Perfect.
Krispy Kremes at Krispy Kreme sponsorship with you on stage with a box of Krispy
Kremes in the middle of your act you start chewing donuts.
Something bigger,
bigger,
bigger company.
Dean has like a motorcycle.
Let's talk about it.
Maybe everybody in the audience gets his donut.
That's a lot of donuts.
It's a lot of them.
I know a lot of water wasted.
We're in a drought,
right?
About Samsung.
Oh,
we'll get Brian holding it up.
All right,
we're out of here,
Esther.
Cool.
We're gonna play this.
Can you feel my menstrual pain again?
E S t.
H.
E.
R.
K.
You on Twitter.
Thank you so much,
uh,
to everybody else.
We'll be back next week.
So thanks for tuning in and much love,
big kiss.
Bye Bye.
Don't go down on you.
But
time and time,
I want to know,
okay.
I want to
know,
Eh,
when I get
the
my dress,
don't be scared.
When I start
feeling eats,
they line champ stamp.
I want to know
the,
I want to know,
can you feel
[inaudible]?
Yeah,
yeah.